WILL BEGIN AND SIXTY WELL WE
ALREADY ANNOUNCED THAT WE'RE
GETTING STARTED LEGEND GERMAN.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY INTO PREP PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING ON
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRACTICE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. OUR
MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY ARE
CENTER MORLOCK. YOU ARE CENTER
IS YOUR HAND THERE AND JUST
MAKE SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME THEIR
CENTER CHIANG. THE CENTER
CHIANG ON THE NOT ON THE CALL
YET. SENATOR DOLLY. CENTER
CHIANG IS THERE VERY WELL THANK
YOU CENTER CHIANG TENER DOLLY.
AND SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER SKINNER ON THE
CALL I DON'T SEE HER ON THE
CALL. PERCENTER SKINNER HERE.
SHE MIGHT BE HERE ON THE FLOOR
OKAY VERY WELL. SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MOVE YOUR MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID US IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ALSO ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT A
MINUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
WILL ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY VIA TELEPHONE.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
TO ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION OR PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S.
1-844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO SIX SIX NINE
SEVEN. 052-669-7054 DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGNYOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT WHEN YOU ARE READY.
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING.
AND HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SIR FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I WOMAN MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE PERIOD
HEARING US CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
COME CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING
CYNICAL. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ARE. ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS. OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL WHEN PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND OF. MADAM CLERK DO YOU SEE
A QUORUM PRESENT. NOT YET. OKAY
WE WILL WILL MOVE FORWARD
NONETHELESS UNTIL MAYBE I'M
GIVEN AN INSTRUCTOR INSTRUCTION
AT ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD AS A SUB COMMITTEE
ON THE COMMITTEE TO HEAR
TESTIMONY ON THE TWO BILLS THAT
WE HAVE ON THE AGENDA TODAY
BEGINNING WITH SENATOR.
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD HERE A
2% A. B. NINE ONE THREE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU MR
CHEER ON SENATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE CALDERON I'M HERE TO
PRESENT. EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE.
AS WE ALL KNOW COLBERT NINETEEN
AS IMPACTED ELECTRICAL
CUSTOMERS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
INCLUDING UNEXPECTED CHANGES
AND LOAD AND GROWING ACCOUNT
DEBTS. MINIMUM THIS AMOUNTS TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT IS GONE UNDER COLLECTED.
THIS IS REVENUE THAT WAS
FORECASTED TO BE COLLECTED FROM
CUSTOMERS AND HAS ALREADY BEEN
DEEM JUST AND REASONABLE BY THE
P. YOU SEE. WITHOUT THIS BILL
THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY UNDER COLLECTIONS MUST
BE ADDED TO CUSTOMERS BILLS AND
TWENTY ONE. THIS BILL THIS
WOULD INCREASE. AFTER THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING FALLING UNDER
COLLECTIONS TO BE FINANCED AND
RECOVERED OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS. UNDER THIS BILL THE PC
MUST ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
FINANCE COSTS ARE JUST AND
REASONABLE. IMPART TO MISTER
CALDERON DISTRICT THIS AMOUNTS.
OF CUSTOMERS DEBT HAS DOUBLED
OR EVEN TRIPLED RESEARCH
CLEARLY MANY RATE PAYERS ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO TIME TO
VOTE WE SHOULD NOT AT A RATE
SPIKE ON TOP OF THEIR EXISTING
BILLS THIS BILL HELPS AVOID
THAT PROBLEM. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO AV TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE TO ASK TESTIFIED
ENHANCED ANSWER ANY. TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IS ADAM SMITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE WE
GO TO- MISTER ADAM SMITH WE
WILL I WILL LAST THE CLERK. TO
CALL THE ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM WESSEL PRESIDENT THERE
WAS A PRESENCE. MEISTER MORLOCK.
PRISONS SENATE AVAILABLE WAIT
FOR THE CAMERA TO CAPTURE YOU.
CINEMARK. BERLOCQ PRESS THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD HERE.
BRADFORD HERE. CHIANG THANK
PRESENT THANK PRESENTS. DOLLY.
KELLY PRESIDENT. TELL THE
PRESENCE DOT. YOUR MIKE. THERE
OKAY. THERE'S NO MIKE TERRA
CANOE STRAIGHT AGAIN. THIS WILL
HELP YOU. DOT HERE THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HERE HELLO. HELLO HERE HERE TO
THE MIKE THERE YOU GO. MCGUIRE
RUBIO PRESENTS PRESIDENT. RUBIO
PRESIDENT WILL YOUR PRESENCE
SKINNER STERN DOZENS. INTO THE
MIKE PLEASE STERN PRESENT TURN
PRESENT. WIENER PRESIDENT. ALSO
CENTER WINNER TO THE MIKE AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN WINNER. PRESENT
THANK WIENER PRESENT. JERRY
HAVE CORN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE WILL- MOVE ON TO OUR THE
TESTIMONY AND WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE MISTER ADAM SMITH ON THE
LINE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL PART OF THE
PRESENTATION. YEAH YEAH. THANK
YOU. RIGHT CALIFORNIA SEN.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR- INTO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CENTER BRADFORD. THIS SUMMER
HAS SEEN A CONVERGENCE OF MANY
CHALLENGES PUTTING GREATER
FINANCIAL STRAIN ON
CALIFORNIANS DOES TRYING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AB NINE THIRTEEN
SIX ELEVEN ONE OF THOSE
FINANCIAL BURDENS BY PREVENTING
AN ANTICIPATED SPIKE THE
LECTURES TO BILLS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. INSTEAD SPREADING
THOSE COSTS. OVER TIME. THE
TOTAL PANDEMIC AND LET IT MAKE
IT CAN'T. HE SELECT CHRISTIE'S
AND AN INABILITY OF MANY
CUSTOMERS TO PAY THEIR BILLS.
S. C. EATING THE QC AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND WATCHING THESE
TRENDS CLOSELY WITH CONCERN.
INTERPRETING SEP IN A STATE OF
UNDER COLLECTION WHICH MEANS WE
HAVEN'T. YET TO RECOVER THE
COSTS THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
FOR RECOVERY IN RATES. THE
CURRENT REGULATORY PARADIGM
WOULD CATCH UP ON THOSE UNDER
COLLECTIONS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY RECOVERING
BACKLOG COST. YEARS IF WE DO
THIS WE CAN RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASE FOR
CUSTOMERS FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNDER
COLLECTION IN TWENTY TWENTY
THAT WAS RECOVERED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SB RAISED 7% ABOVE
FORECASTED LEVELS. S. B. HE
CURRENTLY ESTIMATES. THAT THE
RATE INCREASE FROM USED TO
AFFECT. CUTTING SALES AND- BAD
DEBT. COULD BE IN THE RANGE OF
47% IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
CANDIDLY NONE OF US KNOW HOW
LONG THIS PANDEMIC LAST. HOW
LONG THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY TAKE.
THIS BILL NINE THIRTEEN PUTS
THE RIGHT TOOLS. IN THE TOOLBOX.
KHALKHAL THIS CHALLENGE. IN
ORDER TO MODERATE THAT ABRUPT
RATE INCREASES STILL GIVE THE
PEACE THE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE
SECURITIZATION PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED COSTS. YOUR FINANCING
ORDERS WHEN UNDER COLLECTION
REACHES A SPECIFIED TRIGGER
POINT. I CENTER BRADFORD
MENTION THE BILL'S FOCUS ONLY
ON THE CAR COMMISSION HAS SEEN
JUSTIN REASONABLE AND THEREFORE
HAVE ALREADY APPROVED FOR
QUESTIONS YOUR LITERACY RATE.
BUILDERS AND ALLOW. SEAFOOD THE
RECOVERY OUT OVER TIME IF
APPROVED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. THE BILL
ALSO PROPOSES A TECHNICAL ONE
WORD DELETION THAT WOULD ALIGN
THE ELIGIBLE CLAIMS PERIOD IN
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WITH THE
UTILITIES INSURANCE POLICY
PERIOD. MINIMIZE COSTS REPAIRS
AND TECHNICAL FIX. BUT RIGHT
NOW ELIGIBLE CLAIMS ARE DEFINED
IN AB TEN FIFTY FOUR. ACCORDING
TO THE CALENDAR YEAR. HOWEVER
AS YOU KNOW WILDFIRE SEASON AND
INSURANCE COVERAGE CREATES
DON'T FOLLOW A CALENDAR YEAR.
ULTIMATELY GIVE THE FUND
ADMINISTRATOR CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY THE
ABILITY TO ALIGN THE ELIGIBLE
CLAIMS PERIOD WITH THE
INSURANCE POLICY PERIOD
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. AND
THEREBY BLOCKING SUBSTANTIAL
COST SAVINGS FOR ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS. REDUCING ELECTRICITY
BILL THIS TIME BACK ON THE
CONCERT TO HELP OUR CUSTOMERS
EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS FOR THESE
REASONS FC STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN AND URGES
YOU'RE ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW WE WILL- BRICK BEGIN
TO HEAR FROM ONE WITNESSES ANY
WITNESSES IN THE THAN THE
CHAMBER. HERE OF. THAT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
NINE HERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF. A.
B. NINE ONE THREE. ANYONE AND-
NO THE PEERS AND NOBODY IS
THERE. OKAY. WE WILL NOW MOVE
INTO WITNESSES WENT INTO
TESTIFIED VIA THE TELEPHONES
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE ONE THREE
WE WILL BEGIN NOW MODERATOR.
THANK YOU CALLERS ON THE PHONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO SHOW YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. ONCE AGAIN IF WE
COULD NOT PROMPT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. OF AB
NINE ONE THREE IF YOU WANT IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE AND YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE ONE THREE PLEASE THE
MODERATOR. PLEASE PROBLEMS THE
SPEAKERS. CERTAINLY AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SHARE YOUR POSITION
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINE ONE
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE ZERO
PLEASE. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME-
NO LINES IN Q. NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
HER NAME WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION. TO NINE
ONE THREE AB NINE ONE THREE.
SEE NON WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF IT AB NINE ONE
THREE ROOM ONE TWELVE NINE.
NONE ARE VISIBLE NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE OF THS
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT THEM TO INDIVIDUALS
WAITNG WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE ONE
THREE. THANK YOU STATE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. IT
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SHARE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION FOR AB NINE ONE
THREE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
LOCAL FIRST APPLYING FIFTY ONE
NINE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSUS BASS-
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO TAKE A FORMAL POSITION- BUT
WE HAVE. VERY GOOD QUESTION-
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT THREE
B. THAT COULD PUT PERMISSION
MAY FIND PROPER COVERING EACH
CUSTOMER CLASS BASED ON THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER COLLECTION-
WE THINK THAT NEED TO BE SHALL.
ASSIGN COST RECOVERY WHICH
SUCKED IN THE CLASS- HE- NEEDS
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
UNDER COLLECTION. THERE AND NOT
PUSHY UNDER QUESTIONS AROUND
THE OTHER CLASSES BUT WE WOULD.
ENCOURAGE THAT CONSIDERATION
AND THAT AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MONTEREY IF
YOU COULD PROMPT AND BIG. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIRED MEMBERS LIVING BRIKMAN
YANNI ON BEHALF OF CLECO THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION. AGAIN
THE BILL'S AMENDED- SO RECENTLY
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO TAKE A
<c.cyan>ORMAL POSITION BUT WE DO HAVE</c>
SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
LANGUAGE- THAT WE HAVE
REVIEWED. SIMILAR TO THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY GROUP SO.
WHAT BEST JUST TESTIFIED TO. I
DID HE HAVE THE- A VERY ROBOT
PRICE THAT IN THEY HAVE I'M THE
LACK AND IN OR TEN SOME OF
LANGUAGE. AND WE'RE HOW THE
RECOVERY WILL TAKE PLACE. MAY I
INTERFERE WITH THAT PROCESS. TO
THAT END WE REACHED OUT TO- SB
THAT SPONSORED THE BILL WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD SOME VERY FRUITFUL
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT TRYING
TO COME WITH TO A REVOLUTION.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO ME- IN THE
CREEK- UNITS CONVERSATION THAT
THERE WAS ANY INTENT BY ACCEDE
TO INTERFERE WITH THE PC
PROCESS AND HOW THEY DEAL WITH
UNDER COLLECTION RECOVERY THAT
UNDER COLLECTION. AND SO WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YASSER
YEAH WOULD HAVE TO BE ON A
RESOLUTION TO THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
MONTEREY CAN FROM THE NEXT P.
PLEASE. THANK YOU LOCAL CLINE
FIFTY TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS A-
HI MISTER CARE TO STASH ON THE
DEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICES ASIAN WERE
ACTUALLY HAD TO HEAR NOT NOT
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING WAS
INJURED THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- BUT THAT WE HAD WE HAVE
HAD. CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR- OR LAUNCH I'M SORRY WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE- AND THE
SPONSORS AND OUR ISSUE IS
WHETHER YOU KNOW THIS BILL IS
WHEN HIS SHIP DISTRIBUTION
COSTS ONLY- WE HAVE BEEN
ASSURED THAT BY BOTH IN SO.
THAT WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL- WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS CLARIFIED
TODAY- WE'RE ALSO SEEKING A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. ON
ISSUES WELL. WELL DO WE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. IT TIME. VERY WELL YOU FOR
MUCH MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR HURTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR ARM
YOU AYE AYE AYES STAND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
JUST WANT TO NOTE. AS WE
CONSIDER. AND HAVE CONSIDERED
FOR DECADES. TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES. THE
NOTION OF SECURITISATION HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT WE'LL TALK ABOUT
IN THE NEXT BILL. AND IT'S JUST
I JUST FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY AREA WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO SMOOTH OUT APPROPRIATELY SO
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE-
SMOOTHED OUT THE CENTER
COLLECTION BY UTILIZING THIS
MECHANISM. AND HENCE WEATHER'S
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY RISKS
AND OR COSTS. TO RATEPAYERS I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO UTILIZE THIS
MECHANISM. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE FOLKS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS SOMEONE WITH A CHRISTINE
ARE YOU SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
ON THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF OF.
THE VARIOUS PARTIES TO TRY TO
GET THIS THING THROUGH SENATOR
BRADFORD AND HIS STAFF TOGETHER
WITH- MISTER CALDERON HIS STAFF
MR LIPPER. AND OTHERS BUT THIS
WAS A LOT OF WORK BUT IT WAS IT
WAS THE RIGHT IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST WHETHER IT WAS WHAT WE
DID WITH THE ENERGY CRISIS
TWENTY YEARS AGO OR- WHETHER
WILL PROPOSE IN THE NEXT BILL.
THAT IT IS INTELLECTUALLY
HONEST TO LOOK AT THIS TOOL. IS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT. THAT WE
WOULD UTILIZE IN DEALING WITH
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA AND FACING RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH S. RIVAL. VERY WELL
ANYONE ELSE- CENTER WINNER. AND
HILL AFTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I HAVE A QUESTION HE WOULD BE
FOR. A FOR ADDISON AS ONE OF
THEM WITNESS SINCE THE AUTHOR
MISTER CALDERON IS NOT PRESENT
IN THE BILL ITSELF. AND THE
QUESTION IS- THE ISSUE IS THAT
THE BILL I THINK IS A LITTLE
BIT VAGUE ABOUT WHETHER- CCA'S
I WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS- THIS
KIND OF- OF OUR FINANCIAL MODEL
AS WELL. I THINK THEY CERTAINLY
SHOULD BE- AND- I WOULD ASK
EDISON ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THIS
BILL CAME IN THE PRINCIPALLY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE POSSIBLE. TO AMANDA- BUT
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT AT
A MINIMUM WE COULD HAVE A%
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL TO
CLARIFY THAT THE INTENT IS TO
INCLUDE CCA'S SO MY QUESTION IS
TO A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
YES HELLO GENERATORS IN BALBOA-
CALIFORNIA SENATE YEAH WE I
THINK HAD INDEPENDENCE MANY
HEARD TODAY FROM THE
REPRESENTED FROM COUNTY CA SOME
REALLY GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH
THEM ABOUT- HOW THE CUSTOMERS.
THAT THEY REPRESENT AND IT
REALLY AREN'T WITH I HAVE USED
AND SHARED CUSTOMERS THE I USED.
TAKE CARE OF THE AND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM IN THE
DELIVERY OF ELECTRICITY IN SIX
YEARS- YOU KNOW HELP. RETURN
THE POWER THERE- THIS IS A- AND
OF THIS BILL THE D. IN OUR RACE
THAT WOULD TALKING ABOUT. WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WAS SHARE%
WITH ALL KINDS WHETHER YOU WERE
BY. ON THE HOW DOES HE SEE A-
OF POWER OR NOT IF HE- INVESTOR
ON YOUR TO INDUSTRY. PRINCIPLE
EDITION APART THE PC AND-
GRANTED US. THIS ACCORDING ON
THEIR CUSTOMERS THEY REPRESENT
IN A GIVEN YEAR PERCENT OF
SOMEONE SUGGEST. SIDE WE ALL
SHARE IN THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PROPOSAL I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
OTHER- AREAS- YOU KNOW HOW
QUICK EDUCATION UTILITY
RATEMAKING IS. RATHER INTENSE
BUSINESS I THINK HAVING GREAT.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM TODAY
AND WE- DEPLETE THAT. UNDER
YEAH. WE'LL CONSIDERING WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FIVE YOU FOR I. HONEST
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL TO
THAT EXTRA IMPORTANT AND SO IN
CALIFORNIA EDISON PLEASE DON'T-
DON'T. LET US DOWN- ON THAT
WERE THIS IS A HI COMMITTEE IS
GONNA BE RECONVENING NEXT YEAR
AND I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE. THAT CONFIDENCE- THAT-
THAT THESE KINDS OF THINGS
HAPPEN BECAUSE IT REALLY SHOULD
BE INCLUDED. AND WILL BE
WORKING WITH MISTER TO SURE
THAT IT IS AN TO- WE HOPE GOT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
EXPRESSING. OF ALLENTOWN THANK
YOU. VERY WELL CENTER. THANK
YOU TO CHAIRMAN AND I WANT JUST
TO STAND AND- OF OUR CITY
SUPPORT OF US SENATOR WIENER'S
COMMENTS RELATED TO CCA'S AND
THEIR INVOLVEMENT AND HOPEFULLY
THAT CAN BE. ADDRESSED AND ALSO
IN. REFERENCE TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S. IN HIS OF.
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT TO THIS
OUTLINING THE BENEFITS OF
SECURITIZATION I THINK WE CAN
AGREE THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES IN CERTAIN TIMES
WHEN THAT IS CRITICAL AND- THE
NECESSARY ABOUT I LIKE TO ASK
THE OF. THE WITNESS FROM OF
THIS YEAR A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
IF I COULD- ONE IS. IT JUST FOR
ME TO GET THE CONTEXT AROUND
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE ACTUAL
NEED. THAT WERE EXPRESSING
TODAY IN THIS IN THIS
LEGISLATION- SO IT IT'S YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH UNDER COLOR HAVE
YOU ACTION. SO FAR THIS YEAR.
IN THE PANDEMIC AND IN THAT NOT
AN ESTIMATE FOR TWENTY TWENTY
TOTALLY WHICH IS FROM JANUARY
TO THROUGH AUGUST YOU. YOU HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS ARE. YEAH I'M
HAPPY TO PASS ALONG THE FIRM
NUMBERS- YOU TAKE CARE STAFF
AND I THINK THE GENERAL TREND
THAT WE'RE SEEING IF WE- YEAH I
KIND OF CONSIDER WHAT WE'VE
SEEN SO FAR UP TO THIS DATE FOR
THE END OF THE YEAR ON THE LOW
END. EDITION OKAY- THOSE TO
WHAT WE CALL KIND OF AREAS OF
UNDER COLLECTION. DECREASING
SALES NOW OF THE- YEAH BUILDING
QUINCY THAT TURNED TO BAD. WE
THINK ON THE END. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PLEASE JUST
PRESS ENTER ON SIX ON. MILLION
DOLLAR. IN THE YEAR TWENTY THAT
WOULD BE. PUT ON TOP OF RATE IN
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
COULD UNDO IT AND THEN ON THE
UPPER AND- BUT WE HIS. YOU GUYS
ARE YOU KNOW JOHN WITH THIS IN
REAL TIME I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING WITH IT
ON THE HIGHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM. EDITION CUSTOMERS
COULD BE FACING. SOMETHING
AROUND A BILLION DOLLARS ON
THE HIGHER EXTREME THE SUMMER
THAT KIND OF WHAT KIND OF THE
RANGE. UNDER COLLECTIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WOULD BECOME
AN ENTREE. INTO TWENTY ONE AND
HEARING CENTERS. FOR PER RATE
INCREASE. ON THE LOW END. THERE
IN TWENTY ONE WORK STATION 7%
RAY INCREASE. ON THE HIGHER END.
TWENTY ONE SO I UNDERSTAND SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT FROM JANUARY
THROUGH AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'VE HAD A SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR- REDUCTION OR
REVENUE. IS THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING. I'M SORRY THAT IT
HAPPENED AT THE TOTAL FORECAST
BASED ON THE TREND SO FAR- I
HAVE TO GET BACK TO ON THE
ACTUAL FIGURES WERE WHO WERE
LESS THAN THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION NOW- WE HAD SOME PRETTY
BAD MONTHS I THINK WE GOT A-
WARM NAY WHICH- IS ACTUALLY IT
IS NOT. HAVING A COUPLE MORE
MONTHS WHEN ELECTRICITY USAGE
INCREASES BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
USING THEIR EIGHTEEN HELPS. TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THAT.
DECLINING SALES. SO THIS IS
WHAT I NEED BEFORE CAN BASED ON
AND SEEN. SO FAR I CAN GET
CALLED AN YOUR ARE ABOUT THE
ACTUALS TODAY. WELL I MEAN THE
WEATHER'S ARE ONE THING WITH
THAT IS AN INDICATOR ROTH OR
REFLECT IN TERMS OF THE
REVENUE- FROM BUILD. AMOUNTS TO
COLLECT THAT AMOUNT WHICH IS
THE DISCREPANCY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO SECURITIZED. SO DO YOU
HAVE A NUMBER THAT FROM JANUARY
TO AUGUST THAT SHOULD REFLECT
WHAT YOU HAVE NOT RECEIVED FROM
YOUR BILLING AND HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE TO LAST YEAR'S PERIOD
OF TIME BEFORE WE HAD. THIS
PROBLEM. YEAH I CAN. I CAN
FOLLOW UP DIRECTLY WITH YOUR
STAFF WORKING GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT I COULD PULL IT UP RIGHT
NOW. OKAY. THIS AT ALL CENTER.
I'M SORRY- NO WELL. YEAH I AND
I DID HEAR MORE COMPLEX HE WAS
ACCUSED TRYING TO PULL UP THE
NUMBERS. YEAH I KNOW IT ANOTHER
QUESTION I CAN ANSWER THAT
HOMES. ARE YOU. LOOKING FOR
THAT. SORRY YES IT IS HERE GOT
IT HERE SO CURRENT TODAY. WHAT
I SAID I GOT MEMBERS. FOUR YOU
KNOW JUNIOR TODAY WE'RE SITTING
SOMEWHERE AROUND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF UNDER
COLLECTION AND I THINK OUR
PROJECTION FROM JULY TO
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE LOW END
SCENARIO IS ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION SO
THAT GETS YOU INTO THE REALM OF
SIX HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
YEAR SO WE'RE ABOUT. TO SEE IN
ABOUT HALF OF THAT TREND OKAY
ON THE LOW END SO FAR TODAY AND
HERE COMPOUND INTEREST SOMEONE
DOING THE SAME THING FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR AND WE MAY BE
IN THE SIX. AND YEAH SIX THIRTY
FIVE SIX FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
RANGE OF UNDER COLLECTION DRESS
FOR AT THE END AND THEN IT
NEEDS TRANSCEND CONTINUING
ESPECIALLY WITH- THE FUTURE I'M
GONNA CONSUMER BUILDING QUINCY
AND DAD DAD YEAH THE CREASE IN
THE WORLD WE'VE IN THE WAY THE
PLEDGE THAT WE WILL NOT BE TURN
OFF ANYONE'S POWER. DURING THAT
TIME OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP IN
THE PANDEMIC OKAY SO WE'RE
SITTING IN A PLACE WHERE
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE UNABLE PAY.
THAT DEBT AND BAD DEBT IS KIND
OF NEAT THE APPROVING AND BE
MORE AT. THE NEW ABOUT THE WE
ARE SEEING IS THAT ONE THING
THAT HAPPENED SPECTER MAYBE
THAT WILL BILLION SO TODAY
ACROSS WHEN I GOT THE NOW.
JANUARY TO JUNE IS AROUND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY RIGHT AND I
DON'T MY QUITE AND THAT WAS
WHEN THEY COME MY QUICK. NOW IS
HOW WILL HOW DOES THAT REFER.
ON LAST YEAR UNCOLLECTED.
REVENUE FOR THE SAME PERIOD OF
TIME. I'M TRYING TO GET A
COMPARISON WHICH LAST YEAR SO
HOW REFER HOW IT HOW IS COVERED
REFLECTED IN THIS. NUMBER YEAH
KNOW I HAVE TO GO BACK TAKE A
LOOK AT ACTUAL THANKS IS.
BETWEEN THE TWO I THINK THAT
WHEN I CAME HERE HE WAS SORT OF
OUR FORECAST RIGHT WHICH IS
INFORMED BY THOSE PREVIOUS
YEARS AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
LIKE MONTH BY MONTH IT'S A
MONTH WE'RE AROUND 7% UNDER
COLLECTED UNDER SOMEONE'S WHERE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LIKE I SAID A
WOMAN MONTH MAYBE 2% UNDER
COLLECTED THEN WE ONE COVERT
REALLY HIT APRIL YOU'RE 14%
UNDER COLLECTED VERSUS OUR
FORECAST. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL KIND OF BASED OFF OF YOU
KNOW WELL FORECAST WHICH IS THE
SALES EVERY YEAR AND WE'RE
WATCHING YOUR CAR AND
DISSIPATING GAIN A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF REVENUE FROM. OKAY
THAT. NUMBER KILOWATT HOUR. AND
IT RECEIVED OFF THAT CAPS TO
SPEAKING THE STATE. UNDER
COLLECTION SERVICE LIKE WHEN
KOBE PRINCESS. THE FIRST MONTH
EIGHT WHERE TO SACK. ABOUT 14%
DECREASE IN THE COLLECTED FROM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT INTO
IF I COULD S. SENATE BRADFORD.
A QUESTION TO AS AN IN YOU MAY
BUT WHY IS THIS DIRECTED ONLY
AT ELECT YOU. AND AN APK ADD OR
WATER UTILITY KNOWLEDGE SIMILAR.
ON MISTER CALDERON CHOI TO.
FOCUS ON THE LECTURE BILL I
THINK THAT A GREATER. ON ON THE
OVERALL UTILITY COST AND WITH
THE LOST REVENUES DURING THE
COLDER- SITUATION. IN LIGHT OF.
RESTAURANTS BUSINESSES IS BEING
CLOSED SO THEY'RE VERY DRAMATIC
IMPACT IN THAT AREA SO WE VERY
WELL PRATICA CAPTURED. WATERING
GASES WORLD BUT I THINK THE
GREATEST IMPACT HAS BEEN IN A
LOT TO CONSTRUCT. I COULD THANK
YOU. VERY WELL WILL TO SOME US
DALIO QUESTIONS COMMENTS. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I
GONNA TAKE A SENATOR HILL FOR
THEM HE ASKED ONE OF THE
QUESTION I WANT TO COMPARISON
FROM LAST YEAR TO THIS YEAR-
THE ONLY OTHER QUESTION I HAD
WAS- WE HAD BAD DEBT SO LISTS
FOR EXAMPLE IS A SAY THAT THERE
ARE COMMERCIALS RESTAURANTS OR
WHAT HAVE YOU. THAT YOU KNOW
BEEN GOING LONG NOT PAYING
THEIR BILL AND THEN THEY GO OUT
OF BUSINESS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THAT THAT DEBT YOU CAN'T
COLLECT IT IS IT GETS SPREAD
ACROSS THE PAYING CUSTOMERS
THAT. ARE LEFT IN THE FUTURE.
HE YEAH THAT'S RIGHT WE HAVE
HIM INTO THE PC YEAH THIS CASE
IN PROCESS FOR ASSESSING HOW
THAT. BAGHDAD WANT TO TERMS BAD
DEBT IS SOCIALIZED ACROSS THE
REMAINING CUSTOMER CLASS BUT
THAT YES- DAHLE YOU'RE RIGHT
THAT'S THE WAY IT GOES AND AS
YOU PROBABLY HEARD COME. SOME
OF THE COMMENTATORS I'M HONEST
A LOT OF THE POST OF THAT OFFER
COMMENTS STILL LEAVES MOST OF
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY ALL OF THOSE
DECISIONS ABOUT COST ALLOCATION
HEY DONNA SECURITIZATION TRUE
THAT PROBABILITIES. PROCESS AND
WE'RE IS NO WAY TRYING TO
CHANGE UTILIZED THE SAME.
FRAMEWORK FOR FROM IN CAN FOUR
AND WE CAN DISCUSS ARE BOUND TO
PAY THE HOW TO SOCIAL PUBLIC
YOU TO CAN. WHERE HE KNOW
PEOPLE YOU KNOW DATA AND
DIFFERENT COLOR OF VIEW AND
THAT REGULAR AGENCY TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A COMPROMISE THAT
WORKS. YEAH WELL ONE OF MY-
CONCERN IS THAT WE LEAVE IT UP
TO THEM YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAD
THE- ENERGY CRISIS. BACK IN THE
DAVIS ADMINISTRATION AND YOU
KNOW THOSE THOSE BILLS WERE CUT
OFF ON THAT. THE COMMERCIAL
USERS MORE THAN THE RESIDENTIAL
AND- AND I AM AFRAID IT TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
DID YOU KNOW THE RATES REALLY
GO OUT BUT NOT AT THE
RESIDENTIAL LEVEL- BUT THEY DID
SIGNIFICANTLY GO UP ON THOSE-
AND I'D- USERS THAT WERE WATER
PUMPERS AND FARMERS IN. AND
MANUFACTURERS ALIKE SO- I'M A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT
LETTING THEM JUST YOU KNOW PICK.
SPREADING OUT I WNT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MADE THATARE GETTING THIS.
RELIEF RIGHT NOW THAT. IS
ADVERTISED OVER TIME THAT THE
YOU KNOW HEY IT BACK AND IT
DOESN'T GET CAUGHT SHIFTED TO.
A SOMEBODY ELSE AND- BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE USING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
THE ONE THAT ASKED TO- THE BILL
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL A TODAY- BUT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THOSE TYPE OF GIMMICKS OR
OR SCENARIOS WHERE. THE PERSON
THAT RAN UP THE BILL. DOESN'T
PAY THE BILL AND IT GOES ON TO
SOMEBODY ELSE THAT'S NOT FAIR
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
MOVE. TO CENTER MORE LIKE DID
YOU WANNA. SAY SOMETHING THERE.
THANK YOU MEASURE- MAYBE JUST
TO RECAP BECAUSE I DID HAVE TO
LEAVE FOR A COUPLE SECONDS
BECAUSE MY HOT SPOT RAN OUT OF
JUICE BUT- IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
IS A TWO PRONGED CONCERN THE
PERSISTENT FACTOR. THE AB
ELECTRIC BILLS SO YOU'RE KIND
OF USING THE ACCOUNTS
RECEIVABLE LEDGER COLLATERAL
FOR THE LATE PAYMENTS AND THEN.
THE OTHER COMPONENT IS A YOU
HAD A DECLINE IN. SALES BECAUSE
OF THE WHOLE OF IT OR WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE. AND THOSE TWO
HAVE COME TOGETHER AND YOU ARE.
SORT OF LIKE THE WATER AGENCIES
THAT TOLD US TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF WATER WE USE FOUNDER
REVENUES DECLINED AND THEN
RAISED OUR RATES TO GET BACK UP
TO. A CERTAIN LEVEL SO I'M I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT A
COUPLE THINGS- YOU'RE SAYING
THAT WE HAVE TO GO TO THE SEE
IF YOU SEE BECAUSE OF A FIXED
RECOVERY CHARGE SAID AFTER.
CREWS. AND THIS. THREE FREES UP.
FINANCING WILL SMOOTH IT OUT
BUSH THE TIMING IS WE'RE SAYING
THAT. THE WHAT THE ELEGANT
SOLUTION TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
WOULD SAY THE SOCIALIZE THE
COSTS AND I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT
YOU CAN DO. IF YOU HAVE A RIVER.
THE NEW DECLINE IN THE FUTURE
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU DOING TODAY
GET READY FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SO THAT. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
REPEAT THIS SHOW. YEAH. IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION ARMONK AND I'LL
I'LL TRY TO ANSWER THIS WAY I
THINK. THE UTILITY TAKES A LOT
OF PAIN AND REWORKS OF OUR
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO TRY AND
COME UP WITH FORECAST OF.
ELECTRICITY USAGE WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW OUR GENERAL RATE CASE
WORKS OUT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH WE
HAVE A NEW LEAD REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN OUR SYSTEM INVESTED
WILDFIRES SYSTEM HARDENING
SESSION CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. WE
HOW TO HELP WHAT IT'S GONNA
COST. AND DO ALL THE THINGS.%
YEAH WE NEED TO DO TO OUR
SISTER SAFE. AND AFFORDABLE
THEN WE KIND OF ASSUME AND
FORTY. YEAH USE WE'RE PRETTY
GOOD AT IT- YEAH ELLIPTICITY
SALES AND THAT'S HOW WE GET TO
OUR RATES AREN'T YOU SEE HOW
MUCH MONEY WITH YOU SEE
AUTHORIZES US TO. GET FROM
CUSTOMERS AND WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY KILOWATT
HOURS ARE GOING TO GET USE.
THAN WE COME UP WITH RATES IN
VERY CONCRETE FORMAT THE
PROBLEM THERE IS. YOU KNOW WE.
DIDN'T FORECAST A CO DEPENDENT.
YEAH DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW. I
DON'T THINK ANY. IN. RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEASURE.
OKAY VERY WELL AND MISSY DO WE
HAVE- ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
COMMENT. WELL THERE ARE NO MORE
COMMENTS SENATOR BRADFORD DID
YOU WANT TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR. DEGREE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE AND I.
THEY'RE NOT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
MISTER CALDERON BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AS A FORMER
EMPLOYEE OF INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY. AND STATE THAT. UNDER
COLLECTION IS NOT NEW. I JUST
THINK THE CURRENT SITUATION HAS
EXACERBATED A PROBLEM AND I
THINK IT ALSO SPEAKS TO THAT
ANTIQUATED. RATEMAKING SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS AS IT
RELATES TO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. AND THE P. YOU SEE.
AND THAT I WOULD DEFEND THE
FACT THAT. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AT A FAR HIGHER
BURDEN. AND POWER DELIVERY
VENICE CCA ALL CCA DOES ACQUIRE
THE POWER BUT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES RESPONSE FOR
DELIVERING POWER READ THE METER
DOING THE BILLING AND THOSE
COSTS ARE PART OF THOSE
STRANDED COSTS THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO RECOVER SO. IT'S
ABOVE AND BEYOND THEIR CORN IN
THE PURCHASING OF POWER BUT
IT'S THAT ACTUAL DELIVERY OF
THOSE POWER THE MAINTAINING
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS
BEEN FACTORED IN AND THEIR-
GENERATE CASE WHICH IS EVERY
THREE YEARS SO IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU CAN ADJUST THAT. ON THE WAY
HOME EVERY SIX MONTHS SO THIS
WOULD BRING US TO THIS POSITION
TODAY I THINK IT'S A FAIR.
PROCESS AND HOPEFULLY ONE THAT
WE WANT TO USE AGAIN BUT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COULD WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION HERE ALL SET CENTER
STERN SORRY. CENTER SURROUNDED
REQUEST TO SPEAK TO YOUR- I'M
SORRY CHARLIE INTENTIONALLY
OVERLOOKED FOR THREE FORTY I
KNOW I OF THE SPIN WANTED SAY
POINTS BY SEN HILL AND SENATOR
WIENER ABOUT- EQUAL TREATMENT
FOR ALL CUSTOMERS AS IN THE
RATE BASE INCLUDING CCA
CUSTOMERS APPRECIATE THAT- THE
ONE QUESTION WAS ABOUT WITH
THERE'S A COST ESTIMATE. OF THE
BOND ISSUANCE. IN OTHER WORDS
HOW. HOW HOW MUCH DO COST TO
ANTICIPATE I REALLY LIKE THE
DESIGN OF SMOOTHING OUT ANY
RATE IMPACTS FROM THIS UNDER
COLLECTION OF JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE IF ANYONE AS THE
MATH RIGHT. RIGHT NOW ON THE
ESTIMATES FOR THE COST OF
INTEREST PAID ON THE BONDS AND
HOW MUCH THAT WOULD ACCRUE TO
OVERTIME. CENTER BRADFORD OR OR
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION EDISON SHOULD
PROBABLY KNOW THIS ONE HAS.
YEAH ED IN ISRAEL HAS JUST
JOINED AGAIN I APOLOGIZE TO THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ADAM I'M
BACK. I'M COULD I GET THE
QUESTION WE ST I'M SORRY I
REALLY DID JUST ONE SIDE
SOMEBODY SENATOR STERN. SIR
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE IN
THE IN. THEY TALK TO I DO CALL
IS WITH COST OF INTEREST PAID
ON THE BONDS SAID JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE IF THERE'S ANY
INITIAL ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE
COST OF INTEREST MIGHT BE I
VERY MUCH. SUPPORT THIS AND-
LIKE THE IDEA OF SMOOTHING OVER
THE RATE IMPACTS JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE IF WE KNOW GOING
INTO IT WHAT THE COST WOULD BE.
YEAH M. I CAN TELL YOU WE JUST
RECENTLY. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
pFINANCING ORDER IN CONNECTION
WITH THE- AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
KIND OF THE WILDFIRE RELATED
COSTS THAT EXISTING FORTY OUT
THERE. AND WE'RE COMING IN
UNDER 3% ABSOLUTELY I THINK
WE'RE- SORT OF. HE THE GOING
RANGE RIGHT. EXCELLENTE YOU AND
IT SEEMS LIKE A TIMELY MOMENT
AND GIVEN THE COST OF BORROWING
IS INCREDIBLY LOW IT SEEMS
TIMELY THANKS. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I.
WHAT I ALSO WANTED TO RAISE THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR THE
CCA'S TO ALSO BE ABLE TO GET
THE KIND OF COST RECOVERY THAT.
WE ARE WHO WOULD BE PROVIDING
IN THIS BILL TO OUR I. O. U.'S
AND I REALIZE THAT THE CPUC
COULD POTENTIALLY DO THAT AND I
KNOW THAT EDISON IS NOW
ANSWERED IN MR- OR SENATOR-
WIENER RAISED IT BUT I WANTED
TO- JUST TO CONVEY IT BECAUSE I
THINK A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
IT'S GOT MAY BE NECESSARY SO
THAT THE CPUC REALLY DOES
UNDERSTAND OR INTENT AND I KNOW
THE AUTHOR WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE AUTHOR
NOT THE AUTHOR SO THE
REPRESENTATIVE MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFIRMATIVELY ANSWER BUT I
WOULD LIKE. THAT TO BE STRONGLY
CONVEYED- BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO US I THINK THIS IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
APPROPRIATE BUT I ALSO THINK IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO EXTEND
THAT NOT ONLY APPROPRIATE BUT
NECESSARY FOR THE CCA'S. CENTER
WHERE YOU DIRECT YOUR QUESTION
WELL. I DON'T KNOW IF MR IF OUR
PRESENTER. CAN ANSWER FOR THE
AUTHOR OR NOT BUT. GREAT SO
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT I THINK
AGAIN THAT'S A REASONABLE
REQUEST BECAUSE THERE ARE COSTS
THAT ARE INCURRED- I'M JUST
SPEAKING TO THAT ASPECT OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY WORKS
THERE COST ARE GREAT. MORE
UNIQUE AND FAR GREATER. THAN A
PARTICULAR POWER SO THAT'S THE
POSITION AND I TRIED TO
ARTICULATE AND MY CLOTHES BUT I
THINK YOU HAVE A VALID ARGUMENT
AS TO. OTHER ENTITIES- BEING
ABLE TO RECOVER THEIR COSTS AS
WELL DURING THE DAY. UNDER
COLLECTION THANK YOU AND MAY BE
A I DON'T KNOW IF WE'VE EVER
DONE SUCH A THING FOR PERHAPS
THE COMMITTEE COULD CONVEY TO
THE AUTHOR WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. OKAY VERY WELL OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION. WE HAD CLOSING
COMMENTS QUICKLY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.AB NINE THIRTEEN
BY SIX SEVEN NUMBER CALDERON.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. SO
HI WESSELS I MORLOCK. BARLACH.
MORE LIKE Y. BRADFORD. MIKE
GIPSON PLEASE. YOU CAN ENTER.
ALL RIGHT THE THIRD SEVENTY.
FIVE BRADFORD I THINK HE'S IN
THE- CHANGE HEY I. THANK BY
DOLLY DALY HI DALY I DOT HI
THOUGHT I. HERTZBERG BY
HERTZBERG HI HILL HI HILL HI
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO. INTO THE MIKE. IF
YOU COULD SPEAK INTO THE MIKE.
RUBIO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RUBIO AYE THANK YOU SENATOR.
SKINNER SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE STERN FIVE
WIENER.FIVE OKAY THAT IT
WIENER I. THIRTEEN AS CHAIR
OKAY THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER BRADFORD WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL THE
NEXT BILL IS- A. B. SIX ONE SIX
FIVE NINE BEING PRESENTED TODAY
BY CENTERS HERTZBERG AND ALLEN
IS HELEN HERE TO PRESENT WITH
YOU OR YOU CAN BE PRESENT IN A
LONG. WE CAN HEAR YOU SO AS
LONG AS YOU ARE HERE YOU CAN
PERCENT WHATEVER YOUR YEAH
MISTRETTA I'D LIKE TO IF I CAN
JUST WAIT A FEW SECONDS AND- WE
WANT TO CENTER ALLEN TO LEAD
OFF AND I'LL FOLLOW UP ON. THE
PRESENTATION FOR JUST A MOMENT
IS IT POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO START
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE HIM JOIN
AYE I'D LIKE IF WE JUST TAKE A
MOMENT IT'S POSSIBLE IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU CAN'T COME IN A
MINUTE ALL OF START. THERE
COMES LESS THAN A MINUTE. YEAH.
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM OUR CHAIR-
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE IN YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE GOT AND NORMA'S
PROBLEMS ON OUR HANDS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE FIRES THAT ARE BURNING
THE STATE WE DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE FIRE CHALLENGES- THIS BODY.
PASSED A BOND MEASURE LAST YEAR
THAT AND REFLECTED THE NEEDS
AND INTERESTS AND CONCERNS-
PARTICULAR WITH REGARDS TO
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY OF ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS I WAS IN SB FORTY
FIVE OBVIOUSLY NOW AND THAT IS
NOT HAPPENING BUT WE WORK-REALLY HARD TO CREATE. A SERIES
OF EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MOST
PRESSING NEEDS IN THE STATE HAS
REGARD TO CLIMATE RESILIENCY
PARTICULARLY IN THE SPACE OF
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY AND THAT IS
INCLUDED FUNDING FOR EVERYTHING
FROM FROM. ARE CONSERVANCIES IN
AND WORK THAT THEY DO IN
REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK TO- TO
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
NOT AND THEN WILD ISLAND URBAN
INTERFACE. WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD- PARTNERS IN
IN FIRE FIGHTING- AND SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO ROLL THOSE. NEEDS AT LEAST
SOME OF THOSE EXPENDITURES INTO
THIS PACKAGE. OBVIOUSLY CENTER
HERTZBERG GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
FINANCING BUT IT'S A CAREFULLY
CRAFED. A PACKAGE THAT COMES
OUT OF THE WORK THAT HAPPENED
WITH SB FORTY FIVE. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AND WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO I'D LIKE TO I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THE DETAILS OF THE
FINANCING. OUTSIDE THE DETAILS
OF EXPENDITURES BUT- WITH WITH
WITH THAT I LOVE TO PASS IT
OVER TO SET HER STRAIGHT TALK
ABOUT. THE FINANCING MECHANISM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALLEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE
MEMBERS- I WANT TO JUST RAISE A
COUPLE OF ISSUES. THAT A PART
OF THIS LARGER DISCUSSION. ONE
EMPHASIZE WHAT. SENATE ALLEN
TALKED ABOUT. FOURTEEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED FIREFIGHTERS RIGHT
NOW IS RECEIVING THIS COMMITTEE
ARE FIGHTING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIRES ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BRIEFING THIS
MORNING. ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
ACRES THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE LAST YEAR LAST
YEAR AT THIS TIME ONLY FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES. WE ARE
FACING AN EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE. THE QUESTION IS WHAT
ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT IT. WELL
THESE UTILITIES THAT ARE SO
ANXIOUS. NOT TO APPLY THIS
FURTHER TO THE IF THIS FURTHER-
EXTENSION OF MITIGATION. WE'RE
FUNDAMENTALLY ANXIOUS LAST YEAR
TO UTILIZE THIS VERY MECHANISM
TO IMPOSE ON RATEPAYERS
SUPPOSED TO SHAREHOLDERS THE
ABILITY TO TRYING TO LATE. THE
VICTIMS A FIRE SET DEFAULT
TRIANGULATED INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN
NOW. IT DOESN'T WORK AND I HAVE
SOME THEORIES ON THAT. THINK
ABOUT THIS FOR A MINUTE. NOT
ONLY FACING WHAT WHAT I JUST
EXPRESSION WOULD CENTER ALLEN
EXPRESSED BUT COMPARE THAT TO
THE ESTIMATED FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR HIT TO RATE PAYERS FOR
COST OF THE WILDFIRES THAT HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS MEASURE IS A
BARGAIN. IN TERMS OF PREPARING
FOR MITIGATING THE PROBLEM. TOO
OFTEN IN POLITICS WE SPEND THE
TIME RACING UP TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM AFTER THE AIRPLANE IS
AT THE BUILDING. THIS MEASURES
ABOUT DOING MITIGATING MEASURES
TO AVOID THAT BEFORE IT EVER
HAPPENS. THE EXACT SAME FUNDING
MECHANISM COUPLE OF OTHER
ARGUMENTS I WANT TO JUST
ADDRESS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
ME AT LEAST SO. IS TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT THIS SURCHARGE IN
THIS MEASURE. EXTEND THE IS NOT
APPLIED TO QUALIFYING LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS A CUSTOMER'S
YORKSHIRE CITIES FOR MEDICAL
NEEDS. BUT ARGUMENT IS OF THIS
HURTS LOW INCOME FOLKS NOT TRUE.
SAME MECHANISM THAT THE SENATOR
DODD AND OTHERS HAD WORKED ON
LAST YEAR IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
EXACTLY APPLIED HERE EXACTLY
APPLIED HERE. THE OTHER ISSUE
IS. THIS LARGER DYNAMIC ABOUT.
THE IMPACT ON RATEPAYERS AND
WHETHER OR NOT. THIS IS FAIR
WELL THIS BILL SAYS AND TO
AVOID ANY ISSUE I WANT TO QUOTE
PAGE NINE. LINES TWENTY NINE OR
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH THIRTY
WHERE IT SAYS. THE MONEY SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED PROPORTIONALLY
WITHIN THE SERVICE AREA OF THE
LARGE ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
AND EXCLUSIVELY WITHIN THE
SERVICE AREA WITHIN THESE
AREAS. IT'S THAT'S ONE
REFERENCES ANOTHER REFERENCE ON
PAGE TWENTY LINE TWENTY NINE.
THE POINT IS THAT IF THIS IS
RATEPAYER MONEY. THE RATEPAYER
MONEY IS TO BE UTILIZED ONLY IN
RATE SO SAN DIEGO AT SAN
DIEGO'S MONEY P. JEANNIE IT'S
MONEY AND EDISON IT'S MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THESE
CHALLENGES WITH THESE FIRES ARE
SO. AND CLIMATECHANGE AND THE
NUMBER OF LIGHTNING STRIKES IN
THE IMPACT YOU KNOW SOMEONE
ARGUES WELL THESE WERE CAUSED
BY LIGHTNING STRIKES WELL LET'S
ASSUME THAT. THE LIGHTNING
STRIKES THEN CAUSED A SPARK IN
THE TRANSFORMER AND YOU CAN'T
MAKE A DETERMINATION. WE'RE
TRYING TO MARY WHAT WE DID LAST
YEAR TEN FIFTY FOUR. WITH A
VERY ELEGANT APPROACH IN TERMS
OF WHAT CENTER ISLAND SENATORS
STARTED. SEVERAL MULLIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER C.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. EVERYBODY
SPENT WELL OVER TWO YEARS
NEGOTIATING OF COURSE ARE. THE
STEAM. ORTHODOX MEMBER OVER
THERE SENATOR STERN BEGAN WHO
WORK SO HARD ON THIS TO TRY TO
MARRY THESE TWO CONCEPTS AT A
TIME WHEN WE'RE FACING SUCH A
CRISIS WHERE WE HAVE SPENT
YEARS WORKING LITERALLY ON THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE FINANCIAL
PIECE AND YEARS WORKING ON AND
PULLING OUT OF THE THOSE BOND
MEASURES THAT WE'RE GONNA GO ON
THE BALLOT OR SOME DISCUSSION
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT BONDS BUT
THIS ISN'T BONDS THIS IS RARE
MONEY. REDUCING THEIR RISK
PROFILE IN THIS REGARD. AND THE
ARGUMENT THAT I'VE HEARD FROM.
I GET IT I SAW. US ONE OF THE
SENATORS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT AND
REPAIRS HE'S RIGHT. LARGE
REPAIRS THEY PAY MOE. WE HAVE
OBSERVED JURISPRUDENTIAL MATTER
MAY DETERMINATION THAT POOR
PEOPLE PAY LESS. RESIDENTIAL'S
PAY SOME PORTION AND
COMMERCIALS PAY MORE THAT HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT THIS BODY
HAS DIED IN THIS GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE FOR MANY YEARS NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT. BUT RIGHT NOW AS WE
STAND HERE TODAY THERE'S NO
INCREASE IN FEES IT'S EXACTLY
THE SAME FEE. THAT B. IS BEEN
EXTENDED UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT CENTER DODD INCIDENT OF A
SUMMER HOLDEN OTHERS NEGOTIATED
UP UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
AND THIS JUST SIMPLY EXTENDS
THIS TIME FOR IT TO BE ABLE TO
GET A REVENUE STREAM AND
SENATOR STERN WAS JUST TALKING
IS IT RELATED TO THE LAST
MEASURE ABOUT HOW CHEAP MONEY
AS EVERYBODY WE TALKED TO ALL
THE EXPERTS SAY. NOW IS THE
TIME TO THINK ABOUT THIS IS I
CLOSER TO PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS MONEY IS THE
CHEAPEST IT CAN BE. FOURTEEN
BASIS POINTS ON A TWO YEAR
TREASURY THAT'S LITERALLY JUST
A LITTLE MORE THAN A TENTH OF A
PERCENT. THE COST OF MONEY IS
THE LAST. AND TO. WHEN WE
SPACED FORTY BILLION DOLLARS OF
RISK FROM THE LAST SET OF FIRES
WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THE BIGGEST
I THINK SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT
AS THE BIGGEST. NOW IN STATE'S
HISTORY IF NOT PRETTY CLOSE. N.
SHOULDN'T WE INTELLIGENTLY
THINK THROUGH AND PLAN IN
ADVANCE SHOULD WE LIMIT WHAT
THAT RISK IS TO HELP EVERYBODY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS ONLY
DOES IT FOR THE SERVICE AREAS.
BUT IT IS INDEED A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH. THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS LAST MINUTE BY ITS
NATURE BUT IS JUST COBBLING
TOGETHER. WELL DEVELOPED
COMPONENT PARTS. THAT INFORMED
ONE OF THE BIGGEST EMERGENCIES
WE'VE EVER FACED IN CALIFORNIA
ON TOP OF THE OTHER BIGGEST
EMERGENCIES WE'VE EVER FACED IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THAT I WANT
TO JOIN WITH SENATOR ALAN.
SEMIR BLOOM MULLIN THE TWENTY
THIRTY FROM FORTY SOME CO
AUTHORS IN BOTH HOUSES THAT
ARE. WORKING HARD TO DEAL WITH
THIS EMERGENCY THAT WE'RE
FACING THANK YOU. ALL WE HAVE
IS WE HAVE AS WITNESSES EXCUSE
ME WE'VE GOT TO WITNESSES WITH
US FIRST TODAY'S MISTER SCOTT
WHICH REPRESENT A COALITION. OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY WORKERS TO
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDS THE RSK
IS MEMBERS TOGETHER WITH STACY
HEATON WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ALSO UNDERSTANDS
EXTRAORDINARY RISK THAT THEIR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN FACING
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER. TO MISTER WHICH IF THAT'S
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN YES MISTER
WHICH. REYES WEISEN MIKE NINE
OPERATING. CAN WE TRY AGAIN
MISTER MUCH YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF SCOTT WENT TO BE HAPPY CAL
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES I'D LIKE TO EXPLAIN
TO THE COMMITTEE WHILE WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WHY THE
OPPOSITION'S OPPOSITION IS
SHORT SIGHTED. WE KNOW THE
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
LINES START FIRES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE UTILITIES
JURISDICTION OVER CLEARING OF
THE BRUSH OF DEBRIS AND TREES
IS LIMITED TO FIFTEEN FEET A
MERE FIFTEEN FEET AROUND THOSE
POWER LINES WHEN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FUEL IN THE
FORESTS IS NOT AROUND THE
POWERLINES. SO YOU TO HE'S IN
RATEPAYERS FACE THAT MASSIVE
LIABILITY THEY WILL HAVE TO PAY
EVENTUALLY WE HAVE SUCH A HUGE.
GROWTH BECAUSE OF DEAD TREES
DUE TO DROUGHT IN BEATLES. WE
NEED TO CLEAR THAT FUEL OUT OR
UTILITIES AND RATEPAYERS AND MY
MEMBERS WILL SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES IN THE LONG TERM
THAT'S WHY THIS MEASURE IS
FORWARD THINKING AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY
WELL. MRS HE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. I'M HERE TO
REPRESENTS THIRTY SEVEN RURAL
COUNTIES STATEWIDE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE STARKLY
BORNE AND JORIEN DESTRUCTION
CAUSED BY HIGH SEVERITY
WILDFIRES BUT YOU ALL KNOW AND
WE'VE ALL SEEN THAT RESEARCH
HAS NOW BECOME A WORSENING
STATEWIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS. WILDFIRES ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
COMPROMISED THE QUALITY AND
QUANTITY OF MUCH OF THE STATE
WATER SUPPLY WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT AND THE FIRES
ACTIVELY CONTRIBUTE TO AIR
POLLUTION IN PROFOUND WAYS THAT
EVEN AIRORT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO QUANTIFY ADEQUATELY AT THIS
POINT. AS EVIDENCED BY THE PAST
FEW WEEKS WE KNOW THE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES HAVE A WIDE
RANGING I NEED AND CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE LONGER WE
KEEP DELAYING MEANINGFUL LARGE
SCALE WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
BUT JUST WANT OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL IN FAVOR OF A MORE
REACTIONARY RESPONSE THE MORE
WEEK AFTER WEEK LAST IMPACT ON
OUR COMMUNITIES FORCED WATER.
AND AGRICULTURE AND THE MORE WE
CONTINUE TO STAND ON FIRE
SUPPRESSION AND. REBUILDING
EFFORTS IN THE LONG RUN. THE
LIBRARY. EVERYONE IN STATE FARM
RENDON IN THE TRYING TO ENSURE
THEIR HOME TO CENTRAL WORKER
THAT WORK. AND SMOKE FILLED
KITCHEN. SO SOME OF CAL.
LARGEST INTO WHOSE CROPS ARE.
BY THE CHANGE THE FILE SMOKE.
AND NOTHING. HE FIRED ARE
COSTING REAL HE LIVES EACH YEAR
AND OUR COMMUNITY. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL COULD
FINALLY PROVIDERS- WE NEED
TWENTY STRANGE MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE STATE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EMERGENCY
RESPONSE HOLD. AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY. URGE
OR EITHER TODAY THANK YOU. VERY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL MOVE ALONG TO. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS MEASURE. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH SPEAKERS
HERE. I CAN BARELY CHEERLEADER
SEE YOUR FACE ANYWAY PLEASE
PICK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BY
PHONE ON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON APPLE SUPPORT
RIVERLANDS TRUST'S SECTION
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE A OF
THIS BILL THE FINES- ENTITIES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOME OF THE
FUNDING USES A TERM CALLED
QUALIFIED NON PROFITS BUT IT
DOES NOT ESTABLISH. HAT A
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT IS WE
SUGGEST USING LANGUAGE LIKE AN
ACCREDITED LAND TRUST A
NONPROFIT THAT HAS A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM EITHER
PARTNERING WITH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS OR SCHOOL-
THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
GALLERY OKAY WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THERE IS NO ONE
PRESENT. WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY BY
TELECONFERENCE FIRST MODERATOR.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. A. B. I'M SORRY
THIS BILL IS AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE- MODERATOR THANK. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX FIVE NINE
YOU PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL LINES IN Q. EIGHT LOCAL.
RESEARCHER WILL GO TO THE FIRST
LINE. I DO APOLOGIZE MISTER WE
ABLE TO GO TO THE FIRST LINE.
YES YES PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS MARK PENSION BAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE SMALL TOWN
LOTTERY DEEPLY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION RESOURCE
CONSERVATION. DISTRICT WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO THE
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. BLIND SIX
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BEING HAD CHANGED-
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
BELMONT IN SUPPORT IF YOU. WITH
REGARD TO THE NEXT BIGGER PLACE.
THE LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF BILLS FOR EVERYONE
IN THE COURTS. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK SPEAKER. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER JERRY
MEMBERS VISITING L. LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS GREATER
VALLEY CONSERVATION CORPS AND
CONSERVATION CORPS NORTH
STAYING STRONG SUPPORT. BROUGH
WILL THANK YOU MODERATOR NICK
SPEAKER. BLIND SIXTY SEVEN SIX
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST LITTLE WITH
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE HERE
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING NEXT SPEAKER
MODERATOR. NINE FORTY FOUR FOUR
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOCELYN AND I'M EXPECTING
SUPPORT PARTY THE ONE SIX FIVE
NINE ON BEHALF OF THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLAY MODERATE. BLIND
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BOARDROOM REPRESENTING THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY
WATER OUR BOARD IS TAKING A
SUPPORT IN AMENDED PETITION TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR FIRE
IMPACTED WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WATERSHED IN DOUBLE THE
LANGUAGE OF FUNDING REGARDING
THE PLANET KERR CANAL TO
INCLUDE OTHER WATER CONTAINS
IMPACTED. SERGEANTS THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR NICK WEEK PLEASE.
BLIND EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THE HIGHER
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE IT IN
TEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE
AND ARE NOT SUPPORT BUT WE'RE
NOT OPPOSING I HOPE THIS IS THE
RIGHT KIND SHOULD. CONCERN
ABOUT THE INTERNET CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE WITH AT EIGHT AND YOU
FOR COMBATING FIRED AND MAKING
FIRING AND MAKING COULD TEACH
ME THREE CATASTROPHIC WHY IN
ETERNITY EVENT. HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION AS TO THE
ELLAGIC OF LOCAL IN BILL AND
AFTER THE INCLUDE A PRESS
DISTRICT AND HELL NO INCOMING
THE DECATUR SPECIFIED GREAT IF
HOW IT REMAINS LIKE IF OTHER
DISTRICTS. TO OCTOBER FOR THE
SAME WAY OUR ELIGIBLE EVEN
AFTER EVEN SURE THAT THE VITAL
PART THE MILD RICHARD ARE NOT
ANY EXCLUDED I THINK YOU ME AND
MY WORK ACROSS THE DIVIDING
IMPACT WITH OUR MEMBERS INITIAL
SUGGESTS THAT THE MECHANISM
POTENTIALLY PLACING. I DO COSTS.
IT MAY BE THAT THE BENEFIT THE
COSTS WE WOULD THAT AND- THAT
YOU MAKE THAT THE PROGRAM
FUNDED ARE. AND RIGHT AND HAVE
AT THE AS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATE NXP. THREE
NINE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARYLAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BETH AND POLITICAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AND I'M
EXPECTING SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND THE
FOURTEENTH CERTIFIED LOCAL CORD
THAT REPRESENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT PICKER
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY FIVE TWO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS A- MISTER
SHARON NUMBERS THIS IS ERIN
ADVANCED ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
PART OF THE FRAZIER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NICK
SPEAKER PLEASE. KLEIN TWENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN PAYING OFF
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY SUPPORT OF AB I THINK
THE THING THAT I HAVE PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
AND ALSO. WANT TO THANK OFTEN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON.
THE DOWN THE BURKE COUNTY
PARTNERS. THANK YOU MODERATOR
BAKER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY NINE
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
APPARENTLY. THE PRESIDING
CAUGHT FIRE FIREFIGHTERS AND
THE RESOURCES LEGACY FUND OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
THERE ARE HISTORIC FIREARMS IN
A NEW NORMAL WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING IS THAT BOTH THOSE
DESCRIPTIONS RK ARE SPEAKING OR
SUPPORT FASTERHIS HAIR TO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT
CHAIRMAN IS ONLY AUGUST IS ONLY
AUGUST AND WE ARE FACE SOME
LARGEST THE SECOND AND THIRD.
LARGEST TIRE NAME OPPOSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE MR WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO MAKE A STRONG
INCREDIBLE. STATEMENT THANK.
THANK YOU GOING NEXT. IS MR.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE- JUST
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS NATALIE
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
THE LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS
MAN TRAPPED IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE OVER THE
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE AND PLEASE
ONLY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. NINE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE BRAIN BUT AT THE ON
BEHALF OF YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
RECOGNIZE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
BEEN ON THE INTERNET AND THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. VERY LONG NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. DELINE SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS NATALIE
BERGERON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION AND A
COMPUTER CREEK CONSERVANCY OR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT BAKER. NINE THIRTY THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS SEAN REAGAN
ON BEHALF OF CREDIT EOC LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. VERY WELL THANK YOU A
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER. NINE
FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS ONLY
PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BECOMES MODERATOR. NINE
FORTY NINE FOUR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTEO CHROME
HAPPENED MOUNTAINS RECREATION
AND CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER. NINE SIX
SIX SIX SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOUNG NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. SEVENTY EIGHT
NINE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER TWO CHARGES COULD
NOT HAVE COOL COALITION BUCKLEY
URGING HERE EITHER DID YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE
TWENTY FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF. WHAT
OPENS TRUST THE BIG SUR LAND
TRUST AND SANTA CRUZ WATER
DEPARTMENT INTO COURT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE FIFTY
FOUR FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS DO KERNEY ON
BEHALF OF THE WEYLANDT. I MEAN
PLANT. ALSO WE DON'T WORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
PLANKS EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KAREN MEMBERS OF THE
CEREBELLAR REPRESENTING
SEMPERVIRENS FUND IN SUPPORT.
BROUGH ON XP KERR. ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA I'M ANDREA
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THE
NEXT BIGGER. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
ALL YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS AFRIKA VARGAS AND FOR
THE SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION RECALL.
THANK YOU. VERY WELL OF ARE
THERE ANY MORE SPEAKERS AS
MODERATOR. WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
MORE IN LINE. I'M CLINICS
BECAUSE PLEASE. PRETTY GOOD
LINE SIX THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ARBEL CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON OFFICIAL
WANTED TO BUILD A ON BEHALF OF
THE SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS OF
TOGETHER BAY AREA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY WELL
NEXT PICTURE PLEASE. NINE EIGHT
THREE EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS THAT DID MY CLIENT ON
BEHALF OF CLIENT WATER
AUTHORITY THE POOR AND NEEDY.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS. YES OUR
OUR FINAL LINE IN QUEUES LINE
SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BUCKS I'M EXPRESSING
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE L. A.
CONSERVATION CORPS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE THANK YOU.
VERY WELL. ANY OTHER SPEAKERS.
NO NO FURTHER LINE IN Q. WE
WILL NOW WILL COME TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS I WOULD WISH SPEAK
CENTER HILL. LAKE EFFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
AND- YOUR THIS IS THIS BILL IS
A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
REVIEW AND YEAH THE FASTER
CERTAINLY THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRE. THE WILDFIRES IMPACT
NOT. JUST YESTERDAY MY
CONSTITUENTS WERE ABLE TO MOVE
BACK INTO THEIR HOME THOUGH.
AFTER DAYS OF BEING EVACUATED
YES ARE. I DIDN'T OPPOSITION I
THOUGHT. BUT THAT WAS OKAY VERY
WELL G. DIGITALIZATION YEAH
WE'RE GONNA GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION I'M SO SORRY ABOUT
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO GO- TWO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE MARK TONY WITH THE UTILITY
REFORMNETWORK AND CAN WITH ANY
GAS ELECTRIC ON THE LINES.
WE'LL START WITH MARK STONE IF
HE'S IN LINE NOT WILL GO TO.
CAN CAPS. SURE OKAY THANK YOU
MARK COUNTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF KERN. REPEAT OKAY NO I'M A.
FIFTEEN NINE. REYES BLACK YEAR
ON THE WHILE. DR BY THE- PAID
FOR BY GRAY HERE COULD BE. TEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
FORTY THREE AB TEN FOUR LARGER
RATE HERE INCREASE HISTORY. I'M
HAPPY THAT THEY'RE BILLION MORE
DOLLARS AND REYES HERE AND THE
FULL COOPER MITIGATE CURRENTLY
EIGHTY FIFTY P. WE. AB FIFTY
NINE IS NOT SHORT OF LAND
MINUTE BACK ROOM. REYES. I
BELIEVE I'M OKAY I FOUR GREATER
HERE MY WHILE MANY ONLY TO YOUR.
TO RIGHT NOW HEY LATE THEIR
BOSS HEY BUT YOU COSTA RICA.
BARRING THREE BILLION NOW BUT
THE LADY BIRD READ UNTIL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT REYES HERE
HEY OFF TO SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN. CRITICAL. THIRTY
UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY ONE NOT
THREE ONE PERMITTED SHOULD BE
PAID FOR BY ACT FUNDS IT IS
BARMORE WELCOME PAPER
POLITICALLY. THAN LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME. END UP WE'RE
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TROUBLING IS THERE MIGHT YOU'D
BE BILL WITH YOUR OF BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IS WHO. ONLY BE OF.
YEAH BECAUSE HE TO LOSE WEIGHT
THERE ACT BOOKS DOES NOT. RIGHT
PLEASE VOTE NO. THE FACT ON THE
ARE YOU CUSTOMERS THE PAPER
PROGRAMS COMPLETELY UNRELATED
TO ELECTRIC UTILITY SERVICE.
LOSING MUNICIPAL PROVIDERS FROM
PAYING FARE. WILDFIRES
INCLUDING THOSE STARTED BY
LIGHTNING STRIKES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO HIRE YOU SERVICE
TERRITORIES. EVEN IF COMPLETELY
UNFAIR AND THE PROGRAM SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED FOR WHAT THEY ARE
ATTACKED. THEY WERE BY ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE NOT JUST
FOR CUSTOMERS WILL BE BEDROOM
YOU. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE
MANDATE BECAUSE YOU'D BE A ON
BY PATH WILL BE TO PAY.YET
WHEN DIRECTED DO SO. UNDER AB
TWO FIFTY DO YOU DO YOU CAN
NAME CUTLER'S AND OTHERS FROM.
AND INSTEAD. THOSE GREAT
BLOWING THAT CHARGE RIGHT NOW
MILLION L. CAMINO LOWER INCOME.
CUSTOMERS WHO CANNOT INTO SOLAR
AND OTHER STUFF WITH IT
PANDEMIC WILL FORCED PICK UP
THE- COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY AB
NINE ONE TO HELP. REYES
INCREASES THE NOTRE COMBAT THAT
CAUSED BY THE- YEAH BUILDER
COMPLETE ALL. NOTED CAN FOUR
REQUIRES. AND CUSTOMERS EACH
PROVIDE TEN POINT BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE SEVERAL CAN
MITIGATE BALLPARK RIGHT AT YOU
KILLED. IN WHILE OUR MEDICATION
PLANS. OFF REPAIRS MORE.
COMMITTEE L. NOTE THE IMPACT OF
THOSE VERY CHARGES AND REYES OF
pTO REPAIR STATE STAND BY LIKE
STRIKE BECAUSE FIRES. WATERING
FOR. AMONG OTHER THAT AREN'T.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR- TO
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. AND ON
BEHALF OF ARE YOU. REACT FOR
MOBILE. VERY WELL THANK YOU
WILL GO TO SPEAKER. HERE AND
GALLERY OFFICE. ANYONE WHO IN
THE GALLERY WHICH TO SPEAK
OFFICE. OF AB SIX FOR NINE. NO
ONE IS CURRENTLY VISIBLE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
SEEMS TO BE A VISIBLE THERE
EITHER WE'LL GO NOW TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES IF ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WISHES TO SPEAK
AGAINST A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE MODERATOR PLEASE- Q. THE
SPEAKERS TO SEE HOW MANY ARE
HERE TO SPEAK. AGAINST SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THE STATE YOUR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE SIX FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YOU CAN THAT COMMANDERS ONE OF
THEM ZERO. YOU KNOW. SORRY
PLEASE CALL THE SPEAKERS MISTER
MODERATOR. BUT DID YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TOTAL MISTER CHAIR DID
YOU WANT TO JUST GO THROUGH
THEM YES PLEASE WHAT IS THE
TOTAL. SIXTEEN WE HAVE SIXTEEN
IN Q. ONE SIX SIXTEEN THANK YOU
AT LEAST CURRENTLY THAT THE
MMHM PLEASE MOVE FORWARD
CALLING FOR SPEAKER. VERY GOOD
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AT THIS TIME. I DO
APOLOGIZE COLOR NINE THIRTY TWO
ARE YOU ON MUTE. WE WILL WE
WILL MOVE ON LINE THIRTY TWO
YOU CAN RE QUEUE IT NEEDED.
LINE FORTY SIX LINE FOR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NEVER DID THE TURKEY
USED IN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF FOOD PRODUCERS REPRESENTING
FOOD PROCESSING AND DATA
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO
THE RATE INCREASE THAT WILL BE
A BY EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU. VERY WEALTHY COULD THE
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO BACK TO LINE THIRTY TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU YEAH. YES HELLO THIS
IS BLANCA CASTRO WITH A RP
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION A. R. P.
MEMBERS AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB ONE SIX. FIVE
NINE. AND I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY WE'RE SPEAKING ALSO
ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
A FIXED INCOME OF SOCIAL. WITH
SOCIAL SECURITY AND THEY CANNOT
AFFORD IT AND I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFUL THANK YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT SENATOR HER SURGERY
OR NOT GOING TO HAVE A GOOD
DAY. WE JUST HAVE TO YOU
COLLABORATOR IF WE COULD MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
AND WE ASK YOU JUST TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
AFFILIATION IN. AND NO OTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. MODERATOR
CALL THE NEXT PICKUP PLEASE.
THANK YOU SHARELINES DELAY SIX
PLEASE AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE PAY HOW
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT SOMETHING WE CANNOT
AFFORD RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
NINE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT'S A LOT SO ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND WHO COME
ON THE VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PICKER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. VERY WELL
I THINK. DID THEY FINISH. OKAY
MODERATOR NEXT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE SO. YEAH LINE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LARRY MUNSON WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU NEXT FIGURE
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DR KAREN NUMBERS TO HEARING
YOUR WITHOUT WILL CULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AT
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER PLEASE. LINE FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS QUITE ALMOST CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO NOT
PROFICIENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE FORTY TWO
FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MONDAY AFTER
EIGHT TRYING TO TEACHAND
INSTRUCT OPPOSITION. PRETTY
WELL NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON- EDUCATE
MEMBERS MATTHEW WELL WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. LINE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT TO PLEASE GO AHEA. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS AUDRA HARTMAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LARGE ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING EXPECT HER PLEASE.
LINE SEVENTY TWO SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LAUREN ONLY PAYCHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMER
THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL AIRCRAFT IS THAT
HE CAN CALIFORNIA COUNTRY
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON.
GROWERS ASSOCIATION ARE WITH
THE PARTICULAR IF NEED FARMERS
LEAGUE CALIFORNIA WANTED
COMMISSION AND WESTERN
AKROPOLIS GROUP EDUCATION ALL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. MAN THAT'S
LOWER KLEIN. HEY NEXT NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. BLINDS FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ROBERT SPIEGEL FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION ALSO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
LINE FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY LINE
FORTY SEVEN IS YOUR DEVICE ON
ME. WE'LL GO ON THE LINE FORTY
ONE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER DANIEL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN
GALLERY CAROLYN LOCHHEAD FOR
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY ECHOING THE CONCERNS OF
MY AYE AND YOU COLLEAGUES AND
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
UNDER CUTS THE WORK DONE.
ALLIES I OWE YOU FINANCIAL
HEALTH WHICH WILL HURT OUR
CUSTOMERS. WE ARE CLOSED. NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THANK YOU
FINALLY COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME IS LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL THE ONLY CALIFORNIA
CREATED BECAUSE THE STATION
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WAREHOUSE
ASSOCIATION AND WE MUST
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE THIS
CUSTOMER THANK YOU. VERY WELL
THANK YOU. MR MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE IN TWO. NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY NOW
NOW WE WILL GO. TO THE SENATORS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
CENTERVILLE SORRY CUT YOU OFF
AT THE SURFACE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR APPRECIATED AND- BY. I
GUESS I'LL JUST GO BACK I WAS
THIS IS JUST A DIFFICULT BILL
FOR ME- IN ONE TO REVIEW WHICH
OF THE SOUL CHALLENGING WHEN I
LISTEN TO MISTER WEBB SHOULD
HIS. COMMENTS IN SUPPORT AND HE
WAS VERY CLEAR IN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR THE UTILITIES ARE ONLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FIFTEEN
FEET AROUND. A TREE. AND THAT'S
THEIR LEVEL OF-AUTHORITY
THAT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT'S THE WORK THAT THEY NEED
TO DO WITH THAT IMPLIES THAT.
ANY FIRE THAT STARTS OUTSIDE OF
THAT AREA IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF A REPAIR. BUT THAT'S NOT
TRUE. REPAIRS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT. STARTED OR
NOT IGNITED UTILITY BECAUSE
FIRED IT'S TO TAXPAYERS IT
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
NOT THOSE RATEPAYERS SO THAT'S
THE STRUGGLE THAT I'M FACED
WITH I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES I'VE BEEN WE HAVE A-
OF. THE STATE THE CHECKOUT THE
DOLLARS THAT NEGOTIATIONS
REGARDING THE BONDS THERE HAVE
BOTH YOU KNOW BEEN LIMITED AND
CERTAINLY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
WE NEED THE RESOURCES WE NEED
TO GET THE WORK DONE AND WE
NEED TO CLEAR THOSE- THE
VEGETATION THAT'S CAUSING THE
PROBLEM AND THE THREAT IS NOT
GOING AWAY I JUST IN OUR
DISTRICT- MY DISTRICT THE
RESIDENTS ARE JUST ABLE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR HOMES WHO ARE
EVACUATED- A WEEK AND A HALF
AGO SO IT IS A CHALLENGE I JUST
FOR ME THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
EXPENDITURES PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL. AND THE COST BEING BORNE
BY THE UTILITY RATE PAYERS IS
TENUOUS. HOWEVER NOBLE THE
CAUSE AND NO HOWEVER NOBLE THE
GOALS ARE OF THIS I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
COMMITTEE. AS I. THINK MORE
ABOUT THE ISSUE AND- IN THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY CALIFORNIA
THE LIMITED RESOURCES WE HAVE.
AND THE NEXUS THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THANK YOU FIRST TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR. THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD. OVER
THIS ISSUE IN HIS- ERY
THOUGHTFUL PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
CENTER HILL WE HAVE- MEMBERS ON
THEM ON THE- THAT LIKE TO SPEAK
SENATOR DOLLY THEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND THEN SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FIRST I HAVE A QUESTION FOR- I
THINK- CENTER HERTZBERG GOOSE
WAS DOING THE FINANCIAL PART OF
IT. BY MAY. ASK A QUESTION SO
THERE'S- THATTURNED OUT
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS THAT IT
FAILED ON BONDS AND WE WOULDN'T
EVEN WE WOULDN'T START MAKING
PAYMENTS ON THOSE BONDS INTEL.
FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW UNTIL
WHAT IS EXPECTED TOTAL PAY OUT
OF THIS TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY BY TWENTY
FIFTY ONE THAT'S THE FIRST
QUESTION. OKAY DON'T ANSWER
THAT NOW YOU WANT TO GET THE
EXACT QUESTION TO OKAY I'LL GET
THE NEXT ONE. LEGIBLE WELL
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT
ANSWER BUT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
ANSWER THAT'S FINE YOU CAN
ANSWER YOUR CLOTHES OR
WHATEVER. YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW THAT THE BANKING CHAIRS
ON THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AND
WE TALK ABOUT PREDATORY
LENDING. TO FOLKS WHO. DON'T
UNDERSTAND FINANCING AND YEAH
THISIS IT THIS IS EVEN WORSE
THAN PREDATORY LENDING ANY
PREDATORY LENDING BILLS WE'VE
SEEN. COME THROUGH IN MY
OPINION WE HAVE FIFTEEN YEARS
OF NOT EVEN MAKING THE NEXT
INTEREST PAYMENT. ON UPON. THEY
WERE LOANING THE MONEY FOR
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S NOT ONLY-
IT'S AND IT'S ONLY A SELECT
GROUP OF PEOPLE IT'S NOT WE I
WAS INVOLVED IN. A AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WHICH WAS A BIOMASS
BILL. HAS A FIRE- NINE OH ONE A
FEW YEARS AGO WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER ON IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND I. HAVE BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR- TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
WATERSHEDS IN OUR OUR WILDLIFE
AND SEE THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES BURNED. AND BUDGET TO
NARROW THIS BILL DOWN TO THREE
UTILITIES THREE I USE WHERE'S
THE- WHERE'S THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES WHERE'S THE- WHERE'S
THE NEW NEEDS AND ALL THE OTHER
ONES THAT. ARE GETTING A
BENEFIT FROM. THE RESOURCES
BEING MANAGED AS WELL AND SO
IT'S REALLY JUST NARROW IT DOWN
TO. THE THREE ITEMS SO THAT I
THINK THAT'S- VERY DIFFICULT I
LOOK AT THE BILL THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
THE FRYING CAN NOW. I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S JUST SUPPORT OR
OR THAT'S THE NAME ABILITY BILL
TO GET A BOAT SOMEWHERE. BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF IN THIS
BILL THAT DOESN'T REALLY ADD UP
TO WILDFIRE SO THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF FIRST. QUESTIONS THAT
I HAVE. THAT I YOU KNOW THIS IS
A I THINK IT. THE BILL THAT
REALLY NEEDS A LOT MORE TIME
THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST. AS IN THIS SESSION AND I
KNOW THAT- WE HAVE FIRES
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THE WERE
WERE BURNING DOWN IS
UNPRECEDENTED. BUT IS THIS
REALLY THE ROUTE WE WANT TO GO
IT'S REALLY THAT. THE YOU KNOW
THE FOLKS OF CALIFORNIA
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA'S IS.
LIABLE FOR. THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS INCIDENTS SUCH DISARRAY
FOR LACK OF MANAGEMENT FOR.
OVER THE LAST. SIXTY YEARS O
FOR ME IT'S LIKE WE'RE PICKING
OUT ONE SECTOR THAT'S REALLY
EASY TO- YOU KNOW YEAH THEY DO
CAUSE SOME FIRES BUT ONLY ONE
OUT OF TEN FIRES. ARE CAUSED BY
UTILITIES WE KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT SO. THOSE ARE A FEW OTHER
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
ADDRESSED IF YOU MAY. AS
CENTERS YOU WANT FOR THAT JIM.
BUT THE EASY EXAMPLES DOT WOULD
BE THIS. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AUTHORS AND OTHER AUTHORS IN A
LOT OF FOLKS TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME. ONE THING THAT'S CLEAR IS
THAT BARRING MONEY HAS NEVER
BEEN CHEAPER. SO LET'S ASSUME
YOU COULD ESTABLISH A LOAN FOR
YOUR HOME. AND INSTEAD OF
PAYING 5% INTEREST YOU COULD
PAY A HALF A PERCENT INTEREST
BUT YOU PAID IT ALL AT THE END
INSTEAD OF AT THE BEGINNING.
THE TEST IS WHETHER IT'S A
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND TO THE
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT OF THE
TAXPAYERS. OF ANY KIND OF OTHER
BORROWING THE TEST WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ISSUE THAT YOU TALK
ABOUT A PREDATORY LENDING. IS
WHAT'S THE ULTIMATE COST.
WHAT'S THE ULTIMATE COST AND
THE REALITY IS FROM ALL THE
BEST EXPERTS THAT WE CAN FIND
FROM ALL THE VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS WITH WHOM WE HAVE
CONSULTED. AND ALL OF THE
VARIOUS FOLKS SENATOR A SENATOR
BLOOM AND MULLIN OTHERS AS YOU
KNOW IS THAT MONEY NEVER
CHEAPER AS I SAID EARLIER. IT'S
LITERALLY ALMOST A TENTH OF A
PERCENT FOR TWO YEAR TREASURY.
YOU CAN ESTABLISH THE PRICING
NOW. WE HAVE THE NEED NOW IS
THE STATE'S BURNING UP BECAUSE
YOU HAVE THE NEED FOR YOUR
HOUSE YOUR CAR FOR YOUR FAMILY.
AND THIS IS JUST A PAYMENT
STRUCTURE THAT QUITE FRANKLY.
IS GOING TO BE A LOT CHEAPER
THAN G. O. BONDS OR OTHER TYPES
OF BONDS. THE BETTER I THE THAT
WOULD BE ISSUE. SECOND THING
IS. THAT WHEN YOU READ THE
MEASURE ITS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
BORROWED WHICH IS CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FOR WORK RIGHT
NOW PUT PEOPLE TO WORK DEAL
WITH SOME OF THIS VERY
EXTRAORDINARY REYES FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND THEN THERE
IS THE ISSUE OF APPROPRIATION
FOR THE BALANCE OF THE MONEY.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SCRUB THOSE
ISSUES GOING FORWARD. AND THE
THIRD THING I THINK THAT GOES
TO THE CORE OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THE NEXUS ISSUE AND
YOUR SENATE ALL YOUR 1000%
CORRECT. YOU CANNOT USE
RATEPAYER MONEY FOR NON. RATE
PAIR INTERESTS. BUT THE
ARGUMENT IS GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE SPEND FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS ON ALL
THIS LIABILITY ANYTHING WE CAN
DO. FOR THE REPAIRS TO REDUCE
THAT LIABILITY WOULD BE A
PRUDENT THING TO DO. CHECK A
LOOK BECAUSE THE UNIX. COSTS
ARE CHEAP. IT'S NOT IT'S THE
IT'S THE FARTHEST THING AWAY
FROM. ANYTHING YOU LOOK AT. IN
THE CONTEXT OF. A OF A- A
PREDATORY IN THE LAST THING I
WOULD SAY IS. WE ARE IN TOUGH
TIMES. AND CREATIVE FINANCING
ALLOWS US TO GET THE PEOPLE TO
WORK GET THIS WORK DONE NOW
WITHOUT PUTTING A BURDEN ON THE
BUDGET WITHOUT PUTTING A BURDEN
ON THE BUDGET AND ALSO BY THE
WAY ZERO BURDEN ON RATEPAYERS.
ARE GOING TO PAY A NICKEL A
NICKEL UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY SIX
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO PAY WHAT
WAS UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR NOBODY
HAS ONE. MORE MONEY AND ALSO
JUST TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE IF I
COULD THAT TURN TALKED ABOUT
AND- THE- THE A. R. P. POOR
PEOPLE UNDER THE CARE. OF THE
TICKET CARE CUSTOMER AND THE
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER IS
STILL PROTECTED EXACTLY THE
SAME PROTECTIONS OR INTENT
FIFTY FOUR I THINK THOSE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS. I MADE
MISTER CHAIRMAN- JUST TO OUR
EAST THESE ARE THESE ARE NOT
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ARE THEY- NO
THEY'RE NOT SO THE RATES GOING
TO BE HIGHER THAN THERE USUALLY
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ARE GOING TO
BE A LOWER AND THE OTHER THING
QUESTION I HAD IS WHY ISN'T L.
A. D. W. P. A PART OF THIS THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE SOME
OF. THE BENEFIT FROM THAT. AS
WELL. YES THANK YOU THE REASON
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
WATER AND POWER. AND THE OTHER
MUNICIPAL ONED UTILITIES WOULD
BE. IS THAT WOULD BE A NEW TAX
THAT WOULD BE A NEW FEE ON
CUSTOMERS OVER AND ABOVE WHAT
THE EXISTING FOR YEARS. THE
NOTION JUST LIKE. WAS
ARTICULATED IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT YOU WERE INVOLVED IN. THAT
THIS WAS A CONTINUING OF THE-
AB ONE X. MR KILLIAN TWO
THOUSAND WE DID BACK THEN. AND
A CONTINUE THE FREE. SO NO ONE
WOULD FEEL A GREATER NUMBER. IN
TERMS OF IT IT'S JUST EXTENDED
OUT. THE MEDIA THE- ISSUE AND
MAYBE IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AND THE LAST THING AGAIN.
THE BOND LAWYERS. WHO WILL
APPROVE THESE LOANS WILL NOT
ALLOW. FUNDING THAT IS NOT. THE
IT RELATED TO THE NEXUS AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ITS CONTINUING
APPROPRIATION PROCESS. WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SCRUB
PRECISELY THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISED. I WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FOR THE ANSWERS ARE
TAKING TO ANSWER SOME I JUST
WANT TO WIN ENCLOSING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGING ME- BUT MY QUESTION
AT NIGHT I KNOW THAT MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT. MY FAMILY
HOMESTEADED IN CALIFORNIA AND-
I PLAN ON STAYING HERE FOR A
LONG TIME AND- I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT HOW. WE CAN
BORROW MONEY NOW. AT A LESS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE THE RATES ARE
LOW THAT'S A THAT'S A FACT BUT
WHEN YOU'RE BORROWING MONEY
THAT YOU'RE NOT STARTING TO PAY
ON YOUR CRUISING THAT HALF OF
PERCENT. OVER TIME OVER THE
FIRST FFTEEN YEARS AND I'M
NOT. CONVINCED THAT THAT'S A
GOOD DEAL FOR MY- CHILDREN TO
BE PAYING OFF- OVER THERE
THEY'RE- STARTING THEIR CAREER
SO- FOR THAT AND MANY OTHER
REASONS I THINK THIS BILL IS.
MISGUIDED AND I THINK THAT- I'M
I'M NOT. GOING TO BE A NO VOTE
ON IT AND I'LL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTERED EARLY-
SENATOR STERN. THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER RUBIO THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER CHIANG. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. PRESHEAF THE COLLOQUY IN
THE CLARIFICATION ON THE RATE
PAYER ISSUE WHICH I HEARD
MENTIONED. THANK SOME
MISSTATEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE BY
OPPONENTS TALKING ABOUT RATE
IMPACTS ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
JUST TO REITERATE IS STRUCTURE
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE THIS NON BY
PASSABLE CHARGES NOT PAID BY.
THE LOWEST INCOME RATE PAYERS.
AND THE CARE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
MEDICAL BASELINE. YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S REALLY A QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE WANT TO KEEP THIS.
THIS FIX SURCHARGE SITTING
ASIDE AS A BACKSTOP FOR
UTILITIES. WHICH IS UNDER
CURRENT LAW OR WHETHER WE WANT
TO. PUT THIS MONEY TO WORK
FILLING CRITICAL GAPS. THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW IN OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE RISK MITIGATION BUDGET
YEAR AFTER YEAR IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AS THIS STATE HAS
BURNED. WE HAVE CUT PREVENTION
EVERY SING SESSION. WE HAVE
STEPPED UP ON SUPPRESSION. WE
ARE DOING RIGHT I THINK BY OUR
MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
FIREFIGHTING FORCE BUYING
HELICOPTERS UNISA PRESS WE NEED
TO DO. BUT LAST YEAR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO GO
TO WILDFIRE PREVENTION CUTS.
THIS YEAR ZERO DOLLARS THE HOME
HARDENING BUDGET FOR THIS STATE.
AB THIRTY EIGHT MISTER WOULD
PASSED IT HOW MUCH MONEY IS IN
THE BUDGET ZERO. WE HAVE GIVEN
COMMUNITIES NO TOOLS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT- THE
FORESTRY SIDE OF THINGS AND
SORT OF. THE DEEPER RURAL AREAS
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES. BUT
WHERE WHERE I LIVE AND WHERE SO
MANY PEOPLE LIVE IS RIGHT ON
THE EDGE. IT'S THAT WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE AND THE KIND OF
JOBS OF THIS WOULD GENERATE ARE
NOT JUST RELEGATED BY THE WAY
TO THE FIRE COMMUNITIES ANYONE
CAN GET A GOOD HARD WORKING JOB
AND HAVE A LONG TERM CAREER
PATHWAY THROUGH THE LARGEST
EVER INVESTMENT IN A CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WORK FORCE IN STATE
HISTORY. WITH THIS MEASURE. THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FUND
THIS PUTS TOGETHER IS NOT JUST
ABOUT A TEMPORARY LANDSCAPING
JOB. IS ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE TO
WORK RIGHT NOW UCLA LUSKIN
CENTER DID AN ANALYSIS OF THE
MOST JOBS INTENSIVE. CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS WE CAN MAKE IS A
STATE. AND THIS KIND OF
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE INVESTMENT
IS THE MOST JOBS INTENSIVE
INVESTMENT YOU CAN POSSIBLY
MAKE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A LOT
OF PEOPLE GETTING OUT THERE AND
DOING WORK FOR PUTTING GAS
GETTING ON YOUR VETS SEALING
YOUR ROOF SERVICEMEMBERS CAN'T
GET IN AND BURN DOWN YOUR HOUSE
FROM THE INSIDE DOING THAT
LANDSCAPING WORK. WE LOOK DOWN
ON LANDSCAPERS AND TRY TO TREAT
THEM LIKE- IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
THE GARDENER GUY WITH A LEAF
BLOWER IT'S TIME WE START
LOOKING DOWN ON PEOPLE WHO DO
THAT HARD WORK AND REALIZE THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE MAIN JOB OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GOING FORWARD AND THIS BILL
FINALLY PUT SOME MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS. THERE'S ALSO
MONEY FOR BACK UP POWER WE UST
SAW WE- WE CONTINUE. TO LOSE
POWER AT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN NURSING HOMES
FOR PEOPLE IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHO CAN'T KEEP
THEIR AC ON DURING THE POWER
OUTAGE WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO
GO TO A COOLING CENTER RIGHT
NOW OPTIONS ARE LIMITED THIS
BILL STEPS IN AND ACTUALLY
STEPS UP FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES.
LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY THE
PRIORITIZATION IN THIS FIELD OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE IS
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ORIENTATION.
THERE ARE WEALTHY PEOPLE IN
THIS STATE AND I REPRESENT SOME
OF THEM. IN MALIBU AND
CALABASAS HIGH INCOME MORNING
BRACKETS THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT HARDENING WORK
ON THEIR OWN. THIS BILL IS NOT
DESIGNED TO SUBSIDIZE THOSE
FOLKS BUT WHEN YOU'RE ON A
FIXED INCOME. AND YOU'VE YOU'RE
LIVING IN AN AREA YOU NEVER
THOUGHT WOULD BURN DOWN AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN. YOU DIDN'T DO THAT
GAS GETTING WORK ON YOUR GARAGE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD THAT
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO HAVE
SOMEONE COME OVER AND DO THE
PATCH WORK YOU NEED DONE. AND
THEN YOUR WHOLE LIFE INVESTMENT
BURNS DOWN BEFORE YOUR VERY
EYES. THAT'S A TRAGEDY THAT WE
CAN AVOID. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
WHETHER WE'RE TRYING TO PUT OUR
THUMB ON THE SCALE AND DO THE
WRONG KINDS OF FIRE TREATMENT
IN THESE KINDS OF COMMUNITIES
FOR INSTANCE WE SHOULD HAVE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN SENSITIVE
NATURAL HABITATS WE SHOULDN'T
BE DOING TYPE CONVERSION OR
GETTING. RID OF NATIVE PLANTS
IN FACT USING THAT LIVE OAKS
PREVENT FIRE THOSE ARE NATURAL
BUFFERS- I WOULD SAY I'M
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BUT ALSO WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WILL GET
A SECOND BITE AT THIS APPLE TO
REFINE THIS PLAN AND I HAVE AN
EXPECTATION. THAT WHAT THAT
FINAL PLAN WILL LOOK LIKE IF WE
CAN GET THIS ARCHITECTURE IN
THE LAW WILL NOT PUT A THUMB ON
THE SCALE TO DO THE WRONG KINDS
OF FIRE TREATMENTS IN THE WRONG
KINDS IN NEIGHBORHOODS. IT WILL
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT NO
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN SENSITIVE
HABITAT. AND REALLY MAKE CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT FINALLY
GETTING DOLLARS MOVING ON
PREVENTING THESE TRAGEDIES WE
WILL SAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ACCORDING UCLA'S ANALYSIS
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND JOBS. FROM
THIS INITIAL INVESTMENTS. THIS
IS A GOOD BILL. WE KNOW IT'S
LATE BUT THE CLOCK HAS BEEN
TICKING ON US FOR TOO MANY
YEARS WE CAN'T AFFORD TO SIT I
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVE
MECHANICS DONE BY SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER AND- I THINK
IT'S WORTH MOVING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD IN GETTING SOMETHING
DONE BEFORE WE LEAVE SESSION
THIS WEEK. IF WE DON'T MOVE
WILD FIRE MONEY BEFORE WE LEAVE
THIS SESSION. WE'RE DOING
MALPRACTICE PEOPLE STATED
CALIFORNIA. THANK CENTER STERN
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I WILL FIRST OF ALL
ON I THINK THE AUTHOR AND
ANALYTICAL AUTHORS FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I THINK
THAT TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
ON THIS FLOOR- IN THE SENATE
LEGISLATURE- IS VERY INTERESTED
IN RYING TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH THE
WILDFIRES THAT. HAVE BEEN.
REALLY RAVAGING SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- YOU KNOW I HAD A
FIRE ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO AND A
CAESAR HILLS WHICH IS. MALES
THAT I REPRESENT AND SO I WANT
TO BE. MINDFUL AND THANKFUL TO
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
TO GET CREATIVE WITH MEASURES I
DO BELIEVE WE HAVE TO GET
CREATIVE WITH FUNDING. THAT'S
WHY AS A CHAIR OF INSURANCE TAX
SET UP TO. TO PROPOSE SOME
BILLS TO SEE WE CAN FIGURE OUT
THE FUNDING MECHANISM INCLUDING
BEST PRACTICES FOR MEDICATION-
FIRE RESISTANT MATERIALS AND
OTHER ITEMS THAT I THINK ARE
GOING TO BE HELPFUL I DO AGREE
WITH. WHAT THE GREAT CENTER
FROM- MALIBU IN THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS FOR
FAMILIES FOR PEOPLE TO FIGHT
FIRES AND I ALSO. TO AGREE WITH
THE GREAT SENATOR FOR FROM THE
SENATE TELL THAT.THERE'S A
STRUGGLE HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT OUR RATE PAYERS. WILL BE
IMPACTED I KNOW THAT I
REPRESENT S. C. E. THEY'RE MY
DISTRICT AND SO. I'M VERY
MINDFUL THAT WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE REPAIRS
HIMSELF. THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT BILL AS- THE CENTER
FROM SAN MATTEO EXPRESSED. IT
IS SEVENTY NINE- WE PROBABLY
NEED TO VENT A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT WE KNOW THAT WHERE YOU.
HAVE VERY LIMITED TIME GIVEN
THIS CALL BUT CRISIS AND HOW
LITTLE WE HAVE TIME TO SPEAK TO
PEOPLE. SINCE THE OUR THAT THIS
HAS BEEN IN PRINT I'VE BEEN.
REALLY AGGRESSIVELY BEEN- I
HAVE. CALLED AND TEXTED AND
SENT LETTERS FROM MY DISTRICT
AND- FOR ME RIGHT NOW I REALLY
NEED TO TAKE A LITTLE TIME TO
ADDRESS SOME OF MY DISTRICT
CONCERN. I KNOW THAT I ALWAYS
DO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
PRIDE MYSELF. AND REACHING
REACHING OUT. OF THREE
QUESTIONS WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND THIS IS- CUTTING MY
DISTRICT A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN- AND SO I AGREE WITH
THE CONCEPT I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE AT THE- A MAJORITY
LEADER BUT- AT THIS POINT I'M
JUST GOING TO HAVE TO- STAY
OFTEN I'M- VERY. EAGER AND OPEN
TO HAVE THIS DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR AND- AND RE REACH OUT TO
MY COMMUNITY WHICH WILL BE
IMPACTED AND SEE IF WE. CAN GET
THERE THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG. THANK
YOU MISTER YOU KNOW I JUST
WANTED TO LINE MY COMMENTS ALSO
WITH THAT SENATOR COLLEEN AND-
SENATOR RUBIO AS WELL. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO MENTION- YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE SOME
REALLY GOOD ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL FOR EXAMPLE THE HUNDRED
MILLION. A TO STATE PARKS TO
REDUCE THE RISK WHILE FIRING
RESTORED FIRE RELATED DEATH AND
JUST I HAVE TO KNOW HOW STATE
PARK IN MY DISTRICT AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A GREAT
ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT TO.
EXPAND EXPANDED IN ORDER TO
PROTECT ITS BEAUTIFUL OPEN
SPACE AND WILDLIFE. AND YOU
KNOW I WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. ON YOU KNOW FINDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
PROTECTION AT THE STATE PARK
AND OTHERS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
FINANCING MECHANISM IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS NOT
SOMETHING I CAN SUPPORT TODAY-
I HARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY HE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND HOW
DIVERSE TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
AND YOU KNOW TO GET THE FIGHT I
AM CONCERNED THAT THIS FUNDING
MECHANISM WOULD MEAN ADDITIONAL
COST BURDENS ON ON RATE PAYERS
AND THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE FOR
ME IN MY DISTRICT- AND IF THIS
DOESN'T GET TO THE GOVERNOR I'D
REALLY LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A FINDING OTHER
FINANCING MECHANISMS OR YOU
KNOW. FIGURE SOMETHING OUT OF
IT YOU KNOW FOR SOME OF THESE
EFFORTS SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE BUT UNFORTUNATELY. I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SO BRADFORD. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE MEMBERS AND
SERVICIOS SIMONE BLUM IN HIS
WORK ON THIS EFFORT. BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL ALL
BUT UNDERMINE ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR DID LIVE HERE
THROUGH- AB TEN FIFTY FOUR TO
HELP STABILIZE THE UTILITY
INDUSTRY AND I'M CONCERNED HOLE
CREDIT RATING AGENCIES WILL
VIEW THIS MEASURE AND IT WILL
IT COST TO BE A INCREASED COST
IN BARNEY FOR- THE UTILITIES I
MEAN. I HEARD A WHOLE LOT OF
DEBATE I THINK THERE SHOULD BE
A SHARED COST THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS SIMILAR
TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA STATED A
LOT OF THESE FIRES DIDN'T
HAPPEN AND I OWE YOU TEAR TOLD
TERREUS SOLELY. AND AGAIN JUST
ABOUT 10% ARE STARTED BY A
QUICK MINIMUM FOR STRUCTURE
AGAIN THE FIRES THAT WE'VE
WITNESSED FOR THE LAST MONTH
I'VE BEEN PRIMARILY CAUSED BY
MOTHER NATURE AND WE NEED TO.
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE. I ABOUT
THE AND THE YOU TO ARE NOT
POLICY ALL THESE FIRES THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT WORKING HARDENING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT MOTHER
NATURE HAS BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TIME. IF
YOU TALK TO OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THAT TELL
YOU THEY WALKING FIRE TO HELP
MANAGE. THE FORCED TO THE HOPE.
DANIEL I BROKE AS WELL SO WE
HAVE A BIT OF RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR AS YOU TALK TO SOME OF
OUR FORSTER'S BECAUSE WE FAILED
TO MANAGE BUT I WANT TO GET
BACK TO THE FACT THAT. I THINK
THIS SHOULD BE A SHARED COST I
THINK. ON MUNICIPALITIES AND
THE PUBLIC OWNED UTILITIES-
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED MANY OF
THESE FIRES MANY STARTED IN
THEIR DISTRICT AND I THINK THIS
COST. IF THERE WILL BE A COSTS
SHOULD BE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
SEN I KNOW YOU TERRITORY SO.
THAT'S WHERE I STAND ON THIS
ISSUE. OKAY ANYONE ELSE CENTER
BAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF. I THINK MANY OF
US IN THIS COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAVAGING THE STATE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. IN
THE LAST. IN A TEN DAY SPAN
HERE IN AUGUST ONE POINT SIX
MILLION ONE POINT SIX MILLION
ACRES OF WILDLAND HAVE BEEN
BURNED OUT BY A MAKE A WHILE IN
SIZE IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
HUNDREDS OF HOMES HAVE BEEN
LOST IN LIVES ATTENDED. WHEN
YOU TRAVEL NORTH OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN GET INTO CINEMA
AND LAKE NAPA AS WELL AS
MENDOCINO COUNTY'S. THOSE TWO
COUNTIES OUT OF THOSE FOUR
COUNTIES IN OUR HOME TO NOT
ONLY THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY BUT NOW THE
SECOND LARGEST WHILE IN FIRING
SENATOR DODD'S DISTRICT AS WELL
AS THE DISTRICT. THAT I
REPRESENT IN LAKE COUNTY. WELL
THERE ARE NO SIMPLE FIXES TO
THIS ISSUE. WHAT WE CAN'T DO
THIS YEAR WE CANNOT LEAVE THIS
SESSION WITHOUT INVESTING IN
WILDFIRE PROTECTION AND SAFETY
IN PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE. IN
THIS THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
STEPPED UP TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
UTILITIES BE SECURITIZED THERE
DIDN'T APPEAR TO STAY AFLOAT.
YET WE ARE HERE DEBATING HOW WE
CAN ASSIST OUR COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO STAY SAFE. AGAIN
THERE ARE NO SILVER BULLETS IN
THE TABLE TODAY BUT THIS IS THE
BEST TOOL THAT WE HAVE. RIGHT
NOW TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND SAFETY.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD SEE. A
BILLIONAIRE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH AN AYE VOTE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS ISSUE.
TRY TO SECURE THE FUNDS TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE IN THE BILL
TO STOP THESE HOMES AND THEN
BURNING DOWN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WELL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ANY ANY OTHER.
CENTERS WHICH TO SPEAK. OUT
RESEARCHER. THE LAST CENTER DOT
FILIBUSTER MARLA. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE BILL'S AUTHORS FOR JOCKEYS.
WHATEVER FOR I BRING THIS UP
TODAY THERE ARE YES- THE
SENATOR AND I CONSIDER MCGUIRE
HAS JUST SAID THERE ARE NOT A
LOT OF GOOD OPTIONS. IS THIS A
PERFECT OPTION NO BUT I TOTALLY
AGREE. THAT WE HAVE TO LEAVE
THE SESSION WAS SOMETHING IN IT
AND PLAY IT POTENTIALLY. WITH
OVER FORTY BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT I DON'T REALLY SEE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANY BIG
POTS OF MONEY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE TYPE OF THINGS MOVING
FORWARD- FOR SENATOR- DOLLING-
HE'LL REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE
DOING. IN A FEW BILLS YEAH
BEFORE TEN FIFTY FOUR MOST MOST
NOTABLY TRIED THE ACTUALLY
BEFORE THAT SB NINE OH ONE
EIGHT. SB. NINE OH ONE. JUST
GETTING THE ADMINISTRATION AT
THAT TIME. TO COME FOR WITH A
THE BIG DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THESE FIRES
AND PROBLEMS WAS- YOU KNOW IS
VERY VERY DIFFICULT SO I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE BEST
WE CAN DO RIGHT NOW. IN THIS
FORWARD SOME OF THESE
INEQUITIES WITH WITH REGARDS TO
OTHER UTILITY I JUST DON'T I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S WORTHY OF
A CHANGING THE POSITION OUR
TRAJECTORY OF THIS BILL. THAT'S
AS FAR AS OTHER REPAIRS CAN'T
AFFORD IT THEY CAN AFFORD IT
NOW THERE FORTY EIGHT EVERY
SINGLE- EVERY EVERY SINGLE
MONTH RIGHT NOW WHICH IS GOING
TO LAST A LITTLE BIT LONGER SO
WITH THAT I ANSWER I'M. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER MORE LUCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE I THOUGHT WE'D
SEEN IT ALL- I WAS UP HERE TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN THE LIGHTNING
STORMS HERE TODAY. I'VE BEEN IN
A LOT OF LIGHTNING STORMS BUT
THAT WAS LIKE A WAR ZONE AND IT
MADE YOU WONDER YOU KNOW WHAT
ELSE COULD HAPPEN TO THE STATE-
YOU KNOW WE'RE PROBABLY OVERDUE
FOR A GOOD EARTHQUAKE I DON'T
WANT TO SAY IT BUT IT. MIGHT
YOU KNOW SIX THREE TO TWELVE
CERTAINLY HAD. SOME INTERESTING
ISSUES BUT- THIS IDEA OF
BORROWING- AT A VERY LOW RATE.
IS A VERY STRONG ARGUMENT.
UNLESS UNLESS WE- HAVE
DEFLATION. AND WE FIND
OURSELVES. BAYING WHERE THE
MORE EXPENSIVE DOLLARS. ALONE
IN THE FUTURE IT DIDN'T DIDN'T
IT WILL HAVE BACKFIRED ON US
AND I HAVE NOTHEARD THIS
LEGISLATURE TALK ABOUT AS MUCH
DEBT AS WE HAVE IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ASKING EMPLOYEES TO CUT THEIR
PAY BUT ALL WE DID WAS GIVE
THEM FOR LOS THAT THEY CAN
BANKS AND THEY COULD CASH OUT
LATER THAT'S BORROWING WE TOLD
THEM THAT. THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PAY INTO THEIR PAST ARE OTHER
POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THE
BEST STATS ANOTHER. INCREASING
DEBT THAT'S CLOSE TO. NINETY
BILLION DOLLARS IT JUST WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. HAVING
CORPORATIONS PREPAY THEIR-
INCOME TAXES- IN IN SORT OF A
CERTIFICATE IDEA. WE'RE
BOUNCING AROUND SO MANY IDEAS
ON ON DECK AND WE NEED TO STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA DONE TO TRY TO
ELECTRIFY. THIS STATE AND WE'VE
DONE SOME THINGS IN RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE TRYING I
APPRECIATE BUT WITH THE
STATE'S. HYDRO AND NUCLEAR ARE
NOT RENEWABLE AND THEN THE
FORCE WIND. SOLAR MERA FARMS-
WHICH ARE. YOU KNOW I WON'T
EVEN GO DOWN THAT ROAD- AND
THEN THE IN FORM THE I. O. USE
THAT THEY'VE GOT TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS. AND THEN WHAT DO
THEY DO THEY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE STATE WHAT WHAT
ELSE IS THERE BEING A YANKEES
AND BACK AND FORTH AND THAT
GIVES US THESE. TRANSMISSION
LINES THAT ARE NOW OLD FREIGHT
AND NEED TO BE REPAIRED SO I
WOULD SAY THAT SACRAMENTO HAS
NOT BEEN PROACTIVE IT HAS A
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE. AND
EXIST. SURE THIS BILL IS REACT.
AND IS ARE. DO THIS ACKERMAN
LACK OF. IT'S A LITTLE. BECAUSE
CONSTANTLY YANKING I KNOW YOU
WITH A J. AROUND THE ONE THIS
WAY. AND THAT WAY ALL ITS- IS
THAT CENTRO PLANNING IS A JOKE
A SAD JOKE SO NOW THE SOLUTION
IS X. SIR SEARCH. WHICH IS
TANTAMOUNT TO ATTACK INCREASE
IN THAT IS NOT THE KIND OF
ANSWER WE SHOULD BE GIVING TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THIS IS NOT A
BILL. IT WOULD SEEM MORE
REASONABLE TO PREPARE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN DROPPING OR
MAYBE POSTPONING CERTAIN
IDEOLOGIES AND RUN ARE YOU USED
TO LIKE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
RUN. WITHOUT CONSTANTLY WHICH
SIGN WHAT SHOULD BE. AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A REASONABLE AND
REALISTIC PROCESS TO PROPERLY
ELECTRIFY. CALIFORNIA IN AND
FOR THOSE REASONS AND MORE I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU- CENTER
MORLOCK- FOR MY OWN COMMENTS
FIRST OF ALL. I AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES I THINK IT IS WITH IT
IS A GROWING PROBLEM. AND I
WANT TO THANK CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER ALAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM. FROM EARLY TRYING TO
IRON OUT. THIS PROBLEM WORKING
ON AND I REALLY REALLY BELIEVE
YOU SHOULD BE COMMENDED. FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS AND YOUR
PASSION. HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND- TRYING TO BRING AT
LEAST SOMETHING FORWARD THAT
WILL HELP- WITH BUT FIRE SHOULD.
I JUST HAVE. AN ENORMOUS
PROBLEM FOR YOU FOR USING
RATEPAYER FUNDS TO CREATE A
FIREFIGHTING PROGRAM THE STATE
I THINK WE COULD. DEFINITELY
GENERATE THOSE FUNDS FROM OTHER
SOURCES AND I THINK WOULD BE
MORE PRUDENT I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD EVEN BE ALLOWABLE TO USE
THESE FUNDS SPECIFICALLY TO
FIGHT FIRES A KNOWLEDGE EXPLAIN
WHY I SAY THAT. CURRENTLY OF
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
NEEDS TO BE UPGRADED TO HARDEN
IT. TO MAKE IT MORE RESISTANCE
TO FIRES AND TO. CLIMATE CHANGE
WHICH IS. INSTIGATING WINDS
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN AT AND
MORE VIOLENT THAN MANY OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE EVER COULD HAVE
ENVISIONED. AND SO THESE THESE
FUNDS SHOULD COME FROM REPAIR
FUNDS WE ALREADY HAVE A PROCESS
THAT ALLOWS THAT THROUGH THE PC.
AS I LOOK AT THIS BILL AND I
SEE HOW THEY'RE THEY'RE ONLY
FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW THE DAY-
PRIVATE UTILITIES TO- FIND THIS
THIS PROGRAM. YOU KNOW I REALLY
THINK IT DOESN'T COVER THE
STATE STRATEGICALLY. AND I
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH THE PRIVATE
UTILITIES COVER CALIFORNIA IT
IS A LARGE SWATH BUTTER IN
OTHER AREAS OUTSIDE OF THAT
THEY ALSO NEED TO BE INCLUDED.
IN IN A MITIGATION PROGRAM. AND
THAT NEEDS TO REALLY BE FOUGHT
OUT. AN END TO THE EXTENT THAT
THESE REPAIR FUNDS SHOULD BE
USED TO HARDEN THE GRID I
SUPPORT THAT. AND IF THERE IS
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL THAT WILL
SUPPORT THAT I WILL SUPPORT ITIS WELL IF IT GOES OUTSIDE OF
THAT I WILL NOT BECAUSE THOSE
ARE AREAS. THAT SHOULD BE
INVESTED IN FROM OTHER FINANCE.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD. THAT IS
ILLEGAL COUNTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE. AND CENTER
MCGUIRE I JUST WANT TO. CORRECT
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT THIS FROM
YOUR DISTRICT. BUT IN SAN DIEGO
OUR OUR OUR TRAGEDY STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. WITH THE
CEDAR CREEK FIRES. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WE HAD A FIRE IN
JULIAN THAT BASICALLY DESTROYED
THE ENTIRE. I WOULD SAY MID
MAJOR PART OF THE OF THE JULIAN
FORCE THAT HAS NOT REGENERATED
SINCE THEN. I DRIVE THERE EVERY
NOW AND THEN AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
OF A NEW PINE TREE GROW IN THAT
AREA. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VERY DESTRUCTIVE FIRES ARE.
RAVAGING OUR FORESTS. AND BACK
THEN I REMEMBER A SCIENCE TO
SAY THAT THAT FORCE WOULD NEVER
COME BACK AND HE WAS RIGHT. AND
THAT IS OF EXTREME CONCERN IF
THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN OTHER
PARTS OF STATE I UNDERSTAND
THAT. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE FOUND.%
OTHER OTHER SOURCES TO FIND.
TREE PLANTINGS AND OTHER
PROJECTS BUT- IN SAN DIEGO WE
STARTED ORG HARDENING THE GRID
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE IN SAN DIEGO
RATEPAYERS HAVE SUPPORTED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF HARDENING
PROJECTS. THAT INCLUDE A
WEATHER STATION THAT INCLUDE A
RAPID. RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAVE REALLY HELPED TO
REDUCE NEW FIRES THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY HARMFUL.
THAT TWO BILLION HAS BEEN MADE.
OVER OVER A DECADE. AND HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL AT
MITIGATING THESE WILDFIRES
THAT'S WHY WHEN I SEE THAT
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL AMOUNT
MAYBE A VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THREE. BILLION DOLLARS
BILLION- FURTHER BURDENING
RATEPAYERS IN SAN DIEGO WHEN WE
HAVE A PROGRAM WE'VE HAD
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS TO HARDEN
THE GRID. YES THERE ARE MORE
THINGS TO DO. AND THAT WHAT
THAT PROCESS IS ALREADY ALLOWED
UNDER THE P. YOU SEE AND- THE
PC CAN MORE EXACTLY. ALLOW THE
UTILITIES TO INVEST IN AREAS TO
HARDEN THE GRID. IN WAYS THAT
WILL PROTECT NOT ONLY THE RATE
PAYERS BUT ALSO PROTECT. THE
YOU PUT THE UTILITIES FROM OF
HAVING THEIR EQUIPMENT SPARKED
FIRE SO WHEN PEOPLE TELL ME
THAT THIS IS ABOUT. PARTY IN
THE GRID I DON'T I REALLY DON'T
BY THAT BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE
THAT MECHANISM ALLOWED WITHIN
THE LAW THAT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROP
PROCESS AND SCRUTINIZE. THOSE
PROPOSALS AND REALLY LOOK AT
HOW MUCH MONEY IS GOING TO BE
INVESTED IN HARDENING THE GRID.
AND HOW MUCH IS REALLY HOW FOR
HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO GO TO
HELP PREVENT WILDFIRES AND
DISASTERS IN OUR STATE. BUT I
THINK I'VE I'VE I'VE SAID
ENOUGH I HAVE A HARD TIME
SUPPORTING THIS JUST BECAUSE
HONESTLY I HAVEN'T REALLY HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO SCRUTINIZE THIS
BILL AND THIS IS A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF WHERE I'M COMING
FROM I SEE THAT WE COULD STILL
MOVE FORWARD. AND MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS LAST YEAR WE RAISED
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES AND THAT WAS
IMMEDIATELY THAT'S MONEY THAT
IS HAS BEEN SPENT AND IS BEING
SPENT TO PURCHASE EQUIPMENT TO
COMBAT FIRES TWO OF. WORK ON
SUPPRESSION PROJECTS THAT WILL
PREVENT FIRES AND IF WE CAN
WORK ON SOMETHING ELSE THAT
COVERS THE ENTIRE STATE
STRATEGICALLY AND LOOKS AT HOW
WILDFIRE AREAS AND COMES UP
WITH A STRATEGY I WILL SUPPORT
IT. BUT UNFORTUNATELY I FIND
MYSELF IN A TOUGH PLACE BETWEEN
FRIENDS ON BOTH SIDES AND
INTERESTS ON BOTH SIDES THAT.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE
AND- HIGH IMPORTANT PEOPLE THAT
OF WHICH- I THINK WOULD STAND
TO. BENEFIT ENORMOUSLY BY
PROGRAM. AND WE DO NEED TO PUT
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND-
HOPEFULLY WITH THE WITH WHAT
WE'VE DONE. IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE
WE'VE DONE AND ALL THE VARIOUS
WATER BONDS PARK FUNDS AND
OTHER FUNDS WE'VE- POST AND ALL
THAT MONEY HASN'T BEEN
EXHAUSTED HOPEFULLY THAT COULD
BE- THE EXPEDITED TO GET PEOPLE
TO. START START GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER AND WITHIN ALL OF THOSE
PROJECTS THERE. THERE WAS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT THAT CAN BE
DESIGNED INTO- FIRE
SUPPRESSION. AND READ IT
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF FUEL. IN
THE ENVIRONMENT SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE TO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. I'M SORRY.
THE DOT DALI DO YOU STILL WANT
TO SPEAK AGAIN. WE HAVE A
QUESTION OR WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE
CENTER DOLLY. HERE PLEASE UNDER
YOURSELF. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU I HAD ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR A CENTER HERTZBERG
SO WE DID TEN TEN FIFTY FOUR
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS TO
STABILIZE THE- THE RATINGS SO
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BORROW
MONEY. IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY. MAKE
IT EVEN HARDER FOR THEM TO
BORROW MONEY BECAUSE WE'RE
LAYING OUT BURNING ON THEM
AGAIN A COULD YOU ANSWER ME HOW
THEY COULD IT COULD POSSIBLY
PUSH UP THEIR ABILITY TO BORROW
MONEY AGAIN BY DOING THIS.
ACTUAL PROCEDURE THAT THAT'S
WHY WE DID TEN FIFTY FOUR WAS
TO ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO
SECURITIZE THAT THAT AND BORROW.
GIVE ME. THAT EXACT QUESTION
WAS ASKED OF ME FROM THE C. E.
O. OF PGNIG. WHEN I SPOKE TO
HIM WITH HIS LOBBYISTS
YESTERDAY I GIVE ME THE ANSWER
AND I SEARCH I CONFIRM THAT
ANSWERED WITH THE BEST EXPERTS
IN THE FINANCIAL SPACE. WHO
BASICALLY TOLD ME ONE THAT IN
FACT YOU'RE DE RISKING THE
PROBLEM FOR THE UTILITIES ON
THE ONE HAND. BY VIRTUE OF
REDUCING FIRE RISKS WHICH IS
WITH INVERSE CONDEMNATION CAN
DESTROY THESE COMPANIES. AND
THAT IN FACT YOU CAN ENHANCE
THEIR RATING A THEIR RATINGS.
AND TWO BECAUSE THERE IS NO
BURDEN ON THESE COMPANIES TO
THE OFF BALANCE SHEET FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS THERE'S NO BURDEN
AT ALL IN THE RATINGS. SO IN
FACT IT HAS THE EXACT OPPOSITE
EFFECT OF THE INTENT OF THE
QUESTION I THINK IN FACT HELPS
THE COMPANIES WITH BORROWING BY
DE RISKING THEIR FIRE RISK.
BECAUSE OF THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
VERY WELL TO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY DID YOU WANNA MAKE CLOSING
COMMENTS CENTER HERTZBERG ROUTE
WHERE THOSE YOUR PER CLOSING
COMMENTS JUST A FEW FEW CLOSING
COMMENTS I KNOW WE BOTH WANT TO
MAKE MEMBERS- WE KNOW WE'VE GOT
A HUGE CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
WE'VE GOT OUR STATE IS BURNING-
THIS THIS SENATE PASSED AND
WITH A STRONG MAJORITY. SB
FORTY FIVE AFTER VERY EXTENSIVE
CONSULTATIONS WITH EVERYBODY
HERE- THERE IS A LOT OF WORK
THAT WENT INTO CRAFTING THAT
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE CREATED A SLIMMED
DOWN VERSION THAT HELPS
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE TO
ADDRESS OUR FIRE CHALLENGES-
AND THAT'S WHAT'S AT THE HEART
OF THIS BILL- SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN CAREFUL WE'VE BEEN
THOUGHTFUL AND ULTIMATELY THE
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE HERE
ADDRESS THESE ENORMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURAL CHALLENGES IS
ENORMOUS- WILDFIRE RISK
CHALLENGES THAT WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE AND IN THE END OF THE DAY.
ARE THESE PROBLEMS AREN'T GOING
AWAY AND INVESTMENT THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE NOW CAN MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN SOLVING AND
SAVING MONEY FOR REPAIRS- FOR
TAX PAYERS- AND FOR HOMEOWNERS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS OFF INTO
THE FUTURE THAT'S WHAT. IS AT
THE HEART OF THIS BILL. IT'S A
IT'S AN- NOW THAT WILL PAY OFF
INTO THE FUTURE BY THE WAY IT'S
NOWHERE NEAR AS ROBUST AS IT
NEEDS TO BE. OF IN TERMS OF THE
COST ASSOCIATED- WITH WITH
REGARDS ARE FOR WILDFIRE
LIABILITY LONG TERM BUT IT'S A
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND WILL CERTAINLY
SAVE US MONEY ON THE LONG TERM.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO PASS.
AT THE MICROPHONE OVER TO
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER ALLEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
GRACIOUSNESS AND- PAUL THE
MEMBERS FOR THE TIME OF
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
COMPRESSION THAT WE HAVE. ON
OUR SCHEDULE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE. WANT TO THANK GOD.
THE JOINT AUTHORS- SONORA
BLUMEN MULLIN FRIEDMAN EDUARDO
GARCIA IRWIN LOOSE AND ROBERT
RIVAS. AND WOOD SO THERE WOULD
AMONG THE NUMEROUS CO AUTHORS
IN THE SENATE. YOU SHOULD YOU
ARE CORRECT MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS IS A DIFFICULT TIME AND
IT'S A DIFFICULT CHALLENGE.
ANOTHER WOULD SAY GIVEN TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE HERE THAT
THE COURT QUESTIONS. ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE BALANCING SO MANY
THINGS. TO IT WHAT IF THERE'S A
FIRE TOMORROW. WHAT IS A BIG
FOR TOMORROW AND YOU'RE RIGHT
MAYBE IT MAY BE OUTSIDE THAT
FIFTEEN FOOT AREA MAY BE PART
OF THE TAXPAYERS ARE NOT BUT IT
AFFECTS US ALL RIGHT. WHAT IF
THAT'S HAPPENING WHAT ABOUT
PUTTING PEOPLE TO WORK IN
MARRYING THAT ISSUE WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY ISSUE. WE'RE
TRYING NOT TO PUT BURDENS ON
THE STATE BUDGET WHICH THAT
IMPACTS DEVELOPING DISABLED AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND ALL THE OTHER
EDUCATION OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE CHALLENGES FOR. INCOMING
AND BEING CREATIVE. THE IMPACT
OF THIS IS NOT UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY SIX. THERE'S NEVER BEEN
A BETTER TIME TO BORROW.
SENATOR BILL SENT ME A NOTE AND
I THINK HE'S RIGHT IF YOU LOOK
AT INFLATION FACTORS VERSUS THE
ABILITY TO SET THE RATE NOW.
THAT'S THE KEY WE CAN BORROW
NOW AT A CHEAPER RATE. THE
GOVERNMENT ARE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE ABILITY TO DETERMINE. THESE
OTHER ISSUES WITH THE ABILITY
TO DEBATE THE ISSUE IS TO
NEXUS. AS WE MOVE FORWARD. BUT
WE MAKE A BIG STATEMENT. GOING
FORWARD. THAT THIS REALLY ISN'T
JUST MOVING THE DOLLARS I WANT
TO SHARE. IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOME OF THE BIG RATING AGENCIES.
AND WHAT THE BECAUSE I'M
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS BORING I
THOUGHT WAS CENTER MORE LIKE
CITIES RIGHT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT HE SAID. BUT WHAT
THEY TELL US AS WE FACE THIS
PANDEMIC. THE FIRES AND ALL THE
THINGS. THEY'RE MORE INTERESTED
IS DO WE OFFER A VISION FORWARD
THAN WHAT THE DEBT EQUITY RATIO
IS. DO WE HAVE A PLAN AS A
GOVERNMENT. TO MOVE FORWARD TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THESE
CHALLENGES AND MITIGATE THE
RISK THAT'S THE BIGGER THING
WHEN THEY LOOK TO A RATING
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
I DO KNOW THAT WE OFTEN FACE
THAT ISSUE OF THE YOU KNOW OUR
DEBT RATING IN THE LIGHT. BUT
I'M TELLING YOU WE HAVE VETTED
THIS WITH FOLKS DEALING WITH
THE LARGER ISSUE. I WANT TO
THANK MR LEOPARDS THE CRAVEN I
WANT TO THANK. SORRY OF MY
OFFICE SOMEONE THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE ASSEMBLY WORKED
HARD ON THIS. I THINK THAT THE
ARGUMENT WITH RELATED
TRANSPARENCY IS WRONG. BECAUSE
THIS IS SIMPLY TAKING THESE
ARCTIC PIECES OF ARCHITECTURE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- I THINK HAS
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL. WITH
RESPECT TO A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES TRYING TO. PATIENT
PRIORITY ON THESE THINGS WHICH
I GIVE THEM GREAT. ACCOLADES
AND RESPECT FOR IN THAT REGARD
SO. I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE.
BUT IT IS. DYSTROPHY A TERMS OF
THESE FIRES AND SO WITH THAT
BEHALF OF THE JOINT AUTHORS
PARTICULARLY SENATOR BLOOM WHO
WERE PRESENTING FOR YOU TODAY
AND SOMEBODY OR MULLIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
HERTZBERG CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE PHONE WE HAVE A
MOTION. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JUST TO CLARIFY
CHAIRED THE AMENDMENTS. WE'RE
NOT SPOKEN TO. OKAY ON THE ON
THE MOTION I MENTIONED THE-
AUTHOR REQUESTED THE AMENDMENTS
SO YOU'RE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
AS PART OF THE- WE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. AND MULLIN YES AS
AMENDED YES OKAY THANK YOU.
EIGHTY SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL NOBODY.
WESSON UPLOADING MOORLACH. NO
LUCKNOW BRADFORD. CHIANG CHANGE
NOW HANG THEM. DOLLY ALI NO
TELLING THEM. DOT HI DAD HI
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG I.
HILL. HILL BY MCGUIRE HI
REQUIRED BY RUBIO. NAVALNY
REALLY NOT VOTING SKINNER OUR
SKINNER I. STERN STERN I WIENER.
WIENER HI. M. SEVEN AS M. THREE
KNOWS. MOTION PASSES HER CASE
FOR THE BOOK THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT YEAH
OKAY THE BILLS OUT. OKAY VERY
WELL MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY WILL
NOW. THE GENERAL COMMITTEE WE
HAVE A BY THE WAY BEFORE WE
ADJOURN DO WE HAVE ANY- DID
EVERYBODY GO UP ON THE LAST
BILL. OKAY WELL WE WILL
KNOWLEDGE PERJURED OUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR PARTICIPATION.